sanitaire préparez la fin des
concessions notamment définissant une
doctrine sur le bon état cible des biens
de retour anticiper la gestion future
des autoroutes depuis la publication de
vos travaux de nouvelles publications
sont venus alimenter la réflexion sur
l'avenir du secteur autoroutier je pense
en particulier à la deuxième édition du
rapport sur l'économie des concessions
autoroutières qui a été publiée par la
RT l'Autorité de régulation des
transports en janvier devient 23 mais
également au rapport de l'Inspection
générale des finances sur le modèle
économique des sociétés concessionnaires
d'autoroute d'autoroute qui date de
février 2021 mais dont l'existence a été
révélée que récemment par Le Canard
enchaîné et qui a fité dans la presse il
y a quelques jours aussi monsieur le
Président Monsieur le Rapporteur dans
quelle mesure ces nouveaux éléments
concourt-il à une évolution de vos
constats et recommandations formules en
2022 l'arrivée à échéance des premiers
contrats de concession se rapprochant
pourriez-vous partager avec nous votre
vision de l'avenir du secteur
autoroutier à la lumière de ces nouveaux
éléments de réflexion enfin je
souhaiterais connaître votre point de
vue sur les récentes déclarations
gouvernementales la première ministre
alors de la présentation d'un plan
d'avenir pour les transports et ce qui
c'est la piste d'une plus importante
contribution du secteur autoroutier
Bruno Le Maire a quant à lui indiqué la
semaine dernière avoir saisi Conseil
d'État quant à la possibilité de
raccourcir de quelques années la durée
de certaines des concessions avant de
vous céder la parole pour une durée de
10 à 15 minutes que vous pourrez vous
répartir comme vous le souhaitez je
précise que nous avons fait le choix
d'entendre un grand nombre d'acteurs
d'où la durée maximum maximale de une
heure et 15 minutes que nous avons fixé
pour chacune des auditions de ce matin
c'est pour ça c'est pourquoi en accord
avec l'échelle avec les chefs de fil et
je remercie Didier mandeli chaque groupe
nous avons convenu qu'un seul orateur
par groupe politique interviendrait
disposerait de 4 minutes pour les
groupes les républicains socialistes
écologistes républicains et 3 minutes
pour les autres groupes hormis le groupe
Union santé puisque vous m'avez déjà
entendu et c'est suffisant voilà je vous
fais de la parole
pour nous écouter bon je vais laisser
longuement la parole sur les 15 minutes
qui nous ont répartis à Vincent Delahaye
qui est à l'origine de d'une résolution
présentée par les membres du groupe
centriste et comme vous l'avez rappelé
monsieur le Président la Commission
d'enquête a été constituée le 29 janvier
2020 alors pour vous rappeler vous
donner une note d'ambiance parce que ce
rapport il est conséquent et il est il a
nous avons procédé à une vingtaine
d'auditions avec les principaux acteurs
nous avons visionné la RT nous avons
additionné les ministres en place au
moment de la privatisation
au moment de en 2015-2016-2017 pour le
plan d'investissement autoroutier
important qui a eu lieu
après la loi Macron et nous avons
d'ailleurs au Alexis Kohler
nous avons auditionné 20 une vingtaine
d'auditions et notre rapporteur nous
c'était en plein covid notre rapporteur
a eu une trentaine de d'auditions
techniques et véritablement ce rapport
s'appuie sur une démarche je veux dire
même scientifique mathématiques
je crois que Vincent il faut il faut le
dire puisque nous avons auditionné aussi
les
usagers et nous avons rendu notre
rapport la conclusion du rapport le 6
mai le au mois de septembre pardon le 16
septembre 2020 et nous avons débattu en
séance publique
en séance publique le 6 mai 2021 donc
nous ignorions un peu l'histoire du
rapport de l'IGF
et cette moi je vous remercie monsieur
le Président et votre commission d'avoir
remis cette
ce sujet à l'ordre du jour de notre
assemblée parce que longtemps et à
chaque condition notre rapporteur de la
commission d'enquête a toujours appelé
et les
usagers notamment des nous espérons que
ce n'est pas un rapport pour rien un
nouveau rapport pour rien non ce n'était
pas un rapport pour rien le rapporteur
la rappeler à multiples reprises c'est
un rapport de commission d'enquête donc
nous avons eu des moyens pour travailler
important plus important que un simple
rapport commission d'enquête il y a une
obligation de présence du ministre de
Villepin par exemple Ségolène Royal qui
nous ont expliqué et parfois de manière
un peu surprenante les décisions qui
pouvaient être de cette importance
pouvant être prise mais ça c'est un
petit compte bancaire vous avez un
monsieur le Président rappeler les
recommandations qui sont issues de ce
rapport
ce n'est pas un rapport pour rien bon il
est clair que
au mois de février c'est l'augmentation
des tarifs et cette année dans pleine
inflation une augmentation
jugée quand même très importante enfin
que jugé très important de par rapport
aux difficultés rencontrées par nos
concitoyens ça a mis le sujet sur le en
débat le ministre s'est exprimé suite à
une fuite dans la presse alors on est
prudent parce que Vincent delay il a une
particularité c'est qu'il n'a jamais
rien
nous avons rencontré le ministre Beaune
il n'y a pas très longtemps il y a
quelques semaines pour lui demander un
sujet qui était très important que vous
avez l'objet d'un rapport c'était une
table ronde sur les autoroutes se mettre
enfin autour de la table pour avoir une
discussion et mettre tous les sujets
parce que
c'est toujours très conflictuel c'est
c'est ce regard que nous portons sur les
concessions autoroutières donc il était
dans l'idée d'avoir cette ces assises
alors c'est annoncé par Clément bonne
attendant pour voir les débats enfin le
débats ouverts par le ministre des
Finances je j'espère que ce n'est pas un
contre-feu une espèce de une annonce
faite bon il envoie
la question au Conseil d'État peut-on
raccourcir dans notre rapport en
indiquait quand même que et vous verrez
les concessionnaires puisque vous avez
auditionné on va dire qu'ils sont des
positifs d'un contrat
et globalement le contrat il est plutôt
béton de leur côté avec des juristes de
très haut niveau
et nous avons pu parfois dire que ces
contrats ils étaient déséquilibrés et
largement en faveur des concessionnaires
et que notre travail et nos conclusions
et ensuite Vincent vous parler de
manière plus précise c'était de
rééquilibrer il y a pas un rejet du
modèle concessif même si
certaines de nos collègues ont pu
déposer des des projets de
je te vois donc
il y a des alternatives possibles et il
faut d'ailleurs réfléchir à ou devenir
des concessions et c'est d'ailleurs un
axe important dans les recommandations
du rapport c'est préparé la fin des
concessions alors on a encore peut-être
un petit peu de temps sauf s'il y a un
raccourcissement mais c'est un
feuilleton à suivre attendant le rendu
du Conseil du Conseil d'État sur la
proposition faite par le Ministre
de l'économie mais moi je suis un peu
circonspect sur cette annonce elle tombe
au moment d'une crise sociale majeure
dans notre pays et est-ce que c'est pour
détourner l'attention peut-être c'est
une question que je me pose où
irons-nous avec cette ce sujet mais
merci en tous les cas chers président
d'avoir avec votre commission remis ce
sujet dans le débat de notre assemblée
merci pour ces propos liminaires
merci monsieur le Président cher
Jean-François bonjour à tous
effectivement
Eric vient de le dire la commission
d'enquête a permis quand même de mettre
à plat un petit peu tout ce qui était
autour des concessions historiques les
concessions qui font quand même 9000 km
sur 12000 km d'autoroute et qui sont qui
sont
occupés par trois groupes principaux
Vinci Eiffage et à berthys
on a créé cette commission d'enquête et
on est j'étais à l'origine un peu la
création de cette commission d'enquête
pour que on puisse faire un point
complet sur le dossier et surtout que on
puisse aider le gouvernement et l'État à
rééquilibrer un peu le rapport de force
avec les sociétés concessionnaires parce
qu'on a un peu trop la pression que le
rapport de force il est que dans un sens
et quand on est conséquent on doit aussi
avoir un poids et à mon avis ce poids
était insuffisant en tout cas on l'a
marqué alors
on a on a bien sûr fait beaucoup de
propositions mais je dirais qu'il y en
avait trois principales la première
c'était surtout de ne pas prolonger les
contrats existants d'arrêter le système
de travaux contre progression ce qui
s'est passé en 2015 en fait 4 milliards
de travaux et 3 ans de progression en
fait les sociétés d'autoroute ils
gagnent largement donc la collectivité
il perd et
elle hyper parce que les contrats
historiques en fait il y a un vice à la
base il y a péché originel c'est que on
n'a pas modifié les contrats au moment
de la privatisation ça a commencé avec
Lionel Jospin en 2002 avec 20% de des
autos du sud de la France et puis de
Villepin avec tout le reste et à ce
moment-là c'est vrai qu'il aurait fallu
modifier ses contrats et on fait pas des
contrats de longue durée sans clause de
revoyure il y a aucune clause de
revoyure dans ces contrats moi j'aurais
presque tendance à dire que c'est des
contrats léonards parce que on peut pas
avoir des contrats d'une vingtaine
d'années sont sur clauses de revoyure
donc
c'est ça le vice à l'origine et c'est
vrai qu'aujourd'hui on a l'impression
qu'il faut absolument pas toucher à ces
contrats que dès qu'on touche une
virgule on touche à l'équilibre des
contrats pour les sociétés d'autoroutes
vous écouterez les concessionnaires et
vous leur demanderez comment ils
définissent l'équilibre économique et
financier les contrats parce que c'est
notre deuxième point notre premier point
c'est pas de progression et ça je pense
que
l'action du Sénat a permis d'arrêter ces
histoires parce qu'il y en avait dans
les tiroirs du ministère il y avait
encore des projets de progression contre
des travaux donc je pense que ça c'est
vraiment le premier point il faut
arrêter à minima se dire que les dates
de 2031 à 2036 c'est vraiment des dates
butoir on reviendra peut-être tout à
l'heure un petit peu sur la réduction
éventuelle de ces dates mais en tout cas
c'est des dates plutôt deuxième point
c'est l'équilibre économique et
financier des contrats dans un contrat
de concession c'est le point central
c'est le point central c'est le noeud et
il est toujours évoqué mais en fait il
est jamais défini cet équilibre il a
jamais été défini donc nous dans nos
conclusions on souhaitait effectivement
qui est une table ronde avec les
concessionnaires avec l'État avec la RT
avec tout le monde que tout le monde
vienne autour de la table pour dire
qu'est-ce que c'est que cet équilibre
économique et financier ces contrats
alors nous on l'a on a essayé de le
définir au niveau de la Commission on
s'est dit c'est équilibre économique et
financier des contrats c'est la
rentabilité attendue par les
actionnaires donc les actionnaires quand
ils ont investi en 2006 et en 2002
depuis 2006 ils se sont fixés des
objectifs de rentabilité c'était 8% à
peu près et on s'est dit qu'est-ce que
c'est que cette rentabilité actionnaire
donc on l'a défini on a publié des
chiffres on a pris le risque de publier
des chiffres parce que les sociétés
d'autoroute elle elle nous donnait des
chiffres mais toujours couverts par le
secret des affaires donc vous pourrez
leur poser des questions sur ce secret
des affaires aussi parce que des
contrats qui vont jusqu'en 2036 avec le
un secret des affaires moi ça me fait un
peu rigoler mais en tout cas tout ce qui
nous ont donné on n'a jamais pu le
publier donc on a publié nos propres
prévisions qui sont pas très loin des
leurs
et qui sont pas les leurs et on a publié
nos prévisions et aujourd'hui
2021-2022 ont largement confirmé nos
prévisions et donc à partir de ces
prévisions on a pu calculer la
rentabilité actionnaire soit durée du
contrat parce que les sociétés
d'autoroute vont vous dire la
rentabilité on la verra à la fin des
contrats donc pour l'instant rien à dire
rien à rien à discuter on verra bien ce
qui se passera à la fin c'est à la fin
qu'on comptera les points mais à la fin
ça sera trop tard donc aujourd'hui on
considère qu'effectivement Vinci
notamment à atteint aura atteint les 8%
fin 2023 pour Eiffage c'est fin 2024 et
phase ils ont plutôt des contrats qui se
terminent en 2034 donc ils auront une
dizaine d'années Vinci 2023 ça va
jusqu'en 2036 vous voyez il y a quand
même 13 ans pour abertisse aberti c'est
les le nord et la Normandie eux ils ont
les contrats les plus courts qui se
termine en 2031 et on considère que leur
rentabilité sera atteinte à peu près en
2031 moi j'aurais tendance à dire à
faire deux groupes Abertis où on a à la
limite pas grand chose à qui ne doit pas
dire que il faut pas regarder ce qu'il
faut et mais on a Vinci Eiffage de
l'autre côté sur lesquels il faut quand
même réagir donc cet équilibre
économique et financier c'est
fondamental le rapport de l'IGF qui est
sorti à l'Inspection Générale des
Finances qui était normalement secret
qui a fini par sortir en fait à confirmé
la méthode la méthodologie que nous
avions appliquée au niveau de la
commission d'enquête du Sénat pour
établir la rentabilité actionnaire ils
ont dit qu'il y avait quelques petites
erreurs méthodologiques je conteste
cette cet aspect là dont je vais écrire
Bruno Le Maire pour lui contester les
surmatologiques puisque le rapport de
IGF a repris en fait les réponses de
nourri le président de défage et qui ne
concernait pas en fait la méthodologie
elle-même mais quelques informations
qu'on n'avait pas et bon donc on va
corriger cela mais en tout cas pour moi
c'est validé et c'est quand même un gros
élément de alors
sur ce sujet méfiez-vous l'IGF dit ils
vont avoir atteint 12% à la fin nous on
disait 11 30 on est à peu près dans les
mêmes eaux et
la RT si vous regardez l'Autorité de
régulation des transports eux ils vous
disent ah on a une rentabilité qui est à
peu près à 7,6 donc en fait les sociétés
d'autoroute se servent beaucoup de la RT
en disant regardez la RT il considère
pas qu'il y a une surentabilité en
réalité la RT calcul d'une rentabilité
projet
alors on sait même pas comment il a
calcule parce que si vous regardez bien
leur rapport on n'a pas le détail du
calcul puisque le projet en fait on sait
pas le reconstituer on sait pas
reconstituer le coût du projet donc je
pense qu'ils l'ont fait de façon
théorique mais nous le donne pas il nous
donne pas le résultat on sait pas on
sait pas à combien il siffle le projet
ils disent voilà le projet la phrase
structure elle a coûté tant et on
définit la rentabilité par rapport à
cela nous c'est pas notre optique notre
optique c'est de dire les sociétés qui
ont repris ces contrats ont donné de
l'argent à l'origine c'est des
actionnaires qui ont donné de l'argent
et qu'est-ce que ça leur a rapporté que
voilà c'est c'est ça et ça c'est assez
facile à calculer donc on n'a pas le
même calcul de rentabilité entre la RT
nous le Sénat et l'IGF qui a validé la
démarche du Sénat donc ça il faut que
vous l'ayez bien en tête parce que c'est
un élément très important donc
donc pour nous se mettre autour de la
table et se dire on va effectivement
discuter
discuter de cet équilibre économique et
financier pourquoi c'est c'est important
parce que quand vous avez des contrats
de concession vous avez été élu local on
a pas mal de contrats de concessions les
sociétés concessionnaires peuvent
remettre en cause les contrats si elle
considère que l'équilibre financier
n'est pas celui qu'elles avaient prévu à
l'origine moi ça m'est déjà arrivé en
tant que mère et d'avoir des discussions
obligatoires avec les sociétés
concessionnaires qui disaient ah ben on
avait prévu de gagner de l'argent en
fait on gagne pas pour telle ou telle
raison il faut revoir le contrat et
elles ont le droit de dénoncer le
contrat donc moi je vois pas
parallélisme des formes pourquoi
aujourd'hui on ne pourrait pas dénoncer
des contrats à partir du moment on
considère que l'équilibre économique et
financier est atteint
sur l'ensemble du contrat quand je dis
2023 pour Vinci c'est à dire que les 8%
ils seront atteints même si Vinci fait 0
jusqu'à la fin des contrats entre entre
2024 et 2036 s'ils font un résultat zéro
ce qu'ils font absolument pas mais s'il
faisait ça on serait on serait quand
même à l'équilibre donc voilà donc moi
je considère que l'étape mettre la
pression et l'objet de notre action
aujourd'hui c'est d'essayer de mettre de
la pression sur l'état et sur le
gouvernement de façon à ce que on
rééquilibre le rapport de force avec les
sociétés concessionnaires d'autoroute et
ensuite la troisième recommandation
c'était de préparer l'avenir et votre
commission qui se saisit du sujet à mon
avis est bien dans la ligne de ce que ce
qu'on a fait c'est à dire que il faut
dès maintenant préparer l'avenir même si
les contrats allaient à leur terme
moi ce que je ne souhaite pas donc la
saisine du Conseil d'État par Bruno Le
Maire j'espère qu'on en aura le détail
moi je vais en tout cas je vais en
demander le détail et je voudrais avoir
la réponse du Conseil d'État si le
gouvernement joue la transparence on
devrait obtenir quand même c'est à la
fois les questions et la réponse du
Conseil d'État parce que je voudrais
bien m'assurer que ça correspond bien au
contrat actuel et pas au contrats futur
que réduire la durée des contrats futurs
je pense que tout le monde en est
d'accord après on est d'accord ou pas
sur le système de concession pour ma
part moi je suis je pense que c'est un
bon système à partir du moment on a des
bons contrats et un bon suivi et là on
n'a pas un bon contrat et pendant
quelques pendant un certain nombre
d'années on n'a pas eu un bon suivi donc
c'est vrai que c'est pas c'est pas mon
système sinon on a des sociétés
compétentes qui travaillent bien voilà
qui qui font bien leur boulot et donc la
préparation de l'avenir c'est important
à la fois pour réfléchir ce qu'on fait
est-ce qu'on continue la concession sur
quelle durée avec quel type de contrat
on a des contrats aujourd'hui qui sont
bien mieux ficelés qu'avant est-ce qu'on
fait une société des autoroutes de
France Olivier Jacquin a discuté c'est
vrai que c'est peut-être un sujet
intéressant
même si on a un système concession c'est
d'avoir une société qui permet de
récupérer de l'argent et de le flécher
sur les travaux sur les routes et sur
les infrastructures de transport parce
que sinon on a du mal à flécher
l'affectation des ressources à des
dépenses donc peut-être que c'est c'est
un sujet et en tous les cas il faut
absolument veiller à ce que on est des
infrastructures d'autoroute qui
reviennent en bon état dans les contrats
il est prévu que le concessionnaire
remette en bon état et dans ce qu'on a
vu nous on a plutôt vu une baisse des
investissements sur les dernières années
de contrat ce qui est assez classique
et j'ai l'impression que ça avait un peu
échappé à la DGTM et à la RT mais en
tout cas il faut bien regarder que les
concessions les concessionnaires vont
continuer à investir autant chaque année
jusqu'à la fin des contrats parce que
sinon on aura des autoroutes qui
reviendront en mauvais état donc voilà
je vais peut-être dépasser les 15
minutes je sais pas trop mais j'ai
essayé de vous résumer à la fois par
rapport à la non prorogation des
contrats à l'équilibre économique et
financier contrat et à la préparation de
l'avenir qu'il faut travailler dès
maintenant quel que soit les décisions
qui sont prises même si on a une
réduction des encore plus si on a une
réduction de la durée des contrats et il
faut pas craindre les contentieux parce
que les sociétés d'autoroute elle part
toujours en contentieux vous savez là
elles sont en contentieux avec l'État
aujourd'hui pour une indexation des
taxes d'aménagement on a décidé en 2020
dans la loi de finances d'indexer les
taxes d'aménagement ils disent ah ça va
nous coûter un milliard d'ici la fin des
contrats d'ici 2036 tout cumulé la
baisse de l'IS de 33 à 25% le rapport
jusqu'à la fin des contrats 7 milliards
d'euros
donc voyez il y a un milliard un
milliard il faut un contentieux et les 7
milliards ils empochent tranquillement
de l'autre côté donc il y a un moment
donné où c'est pas possible alors ils
ont beaucoup de moyens ils ont beaucoup
de juristes et ils ont moyen de payer
beaucoup de juristes avec l'argent
public d'ailleurs puisque c'est l'argent
de nous tous de tous les utilisateurs à
un moment donné il faut aussi que l'État
et la puissance publique puisse leur
montrer que on n'a pas peur et que on
n'a pas peur d'un éventuel contentieux
ben voilà si si un contentieux il y a un
contentieux mais d'un autre côté il faut
vraiment que le rapport de force
s'inverse voilà ce que je voulais dire
en introduction monsieur le Président en
espérant avoir été le plus synthétique
possible merci merci donc on va donner
la parole à nos à nos collègues pour le
couple républicains suite d'un appareil
à Laurence Muller Rhône
merci monsieur le Président chers
collègues alors vous nous avez bien
expliqué résumé la problématique donc je
passerai directement aux questions pour
ne pas perdre de temps donc selon vous
comment l'État doit-il aujourd'hui
renégocier ces contrats quelle est la
marge de manœuvre du gouvernement et que
peut-il obtenir pour rééquilibrer les
bénéfices et partager les gains
d'exploitation sans renation
renégociation des contrats quel serait
le montant des pertes pour l'État
à plus long terme est-il envisageable de
réduire au moins de moitié la durée des
concessions et de prévoir des clauses de
modération tarifaire en fonction des
bénéfices et des seuils de rentabilité
quelles sont les pistes envisageables
pour exploiter la rentabilité de ces
sociétés au bénéfice des usagers par
exemple inclure dans les contrats une
réduction significative du prix des
abonnements pour les trajets quotidiens
domicile travail depuis la publication
du rapport de la commission d'enquête du
Sénat avez-vous constaté une évolution
et une ouverture du gouvernement qui se
rapprocherait du constat et des
recommandations que vous avez formulées
mais d'après ce que vous avez dit pas
vraiment en d'autres termes pensez-vous
qu'il existe aujourd'hui une volonté
politique de s'attaquer à ces contrats
une volonté qui va falloir encourager
d'après ce que nous avons compris aussi
alors j'ai également quelques questions
de la part de notre collègue Philippe
Tabarro est-ce que je les vous les
envoie dans la foulée oui
allons-y allons-y alors de la part de
Philippe que pensez-vous des rapports de
l'IGF et de la RT vous nous en avez
parlé en comparaison avec vos propres
conclusions qui avaient été jugées trop
à charge en 2020 feriez-vous les mêmes
constats aujourd'hui et enfin quel
montant les concessionnaires
pourraient-ils dégager pour les affecter
aux rails voilà messieurs merci
merci on va regrouper toutes les
questions et puis tu crois qu'on répond
pas d'abord je pense que c'est
non parce que après bon je dis pas qu'on
va les oublier parce que ces questions
là on se les pose aussi donc très
largement donc on les a en tête mais je
pense que pour la clarté du débat c'est
peut-être pas mal de répondre
immédiatement
alors la surentabilité ce qu'on a
considéré d'abord
honnêtement nos conclusions on les
maintiendrait aujourd'hui on n'a pas de
raison de ne pas maintenir ce que le
travail qu'on a fait il y a rien qui qui
a évolué ce qui évolue quand même un
petit peu c'est quand même la prise en
compte et la prise de conscience du
gouvernement Bruno Le Maire l'a dit à
l'Assemblée nationale elle a été
auditionnée la semaine dernière il a dit
qu'il reconnaissait quand même qu'il y
avait une sur rentabilité ce qui est ce
qui était pas le cas avant quand on
l'avait auditionné on avait auditionné
comme Elisabeth borne ici mais dans
cette salle même et il avait pas reconnu
donc je dirais qu'il y a une évolution
il y a une prise en compte le fait qu'il
saisisse le Conseil d'État pour dire on
pourrait peut-être réduire la durée des
contrats c'est aussi un élément à
prendre en compte donc on sent qu'il y a
une prise de conscience et que cette
prise de conscience elle vient
effectivement du travail qui a été
réalisé à la fois du nôtre mais aussi de
l'aspect médiatique parce que c'est vrai
que le fait que les médias sont saisis
et on parle beaucoup et moi je suis
assez sollicité sur sur ce plan là
ça ça continue et ça procède de la
pression d'ensemble pour que les choses
évoluent parce que la volonté bien sûr
des sociétés d'autoroute c'est que rien
évolue d'ici la fin des contrats et même
que ils puissent pour Oger leur contrat
actuel donc c'est c'est leur discours
c'est dire voilà il y a encore beaucoup
d'investissements à faire on a 60
milliards soit disant 60 milliards pour
verdir les autoroutes on sait pas très
bien ce qu'il y a dans les 60 milliards
mais vous voyez 60 milliards c'est
énorme vous rendez compte et nous ce
qu'on chiffre comme surentabilité ce
qu'on a chiffré qu'on continue
d'ailleurs de vous chiffrer c'est à peu
près entre 30 et 35 milliards à peu près
après après
l'atteinte des des 8% dont j'ai parlé
tout à l'heure donc à partir de 2023
après fin 2023 pour Vinci et fin 2024
pour Eiffage on peut considérer qu'il y
a 30 35 milliards et c'est pour ça qu'on
avait titré notre notre rapport sur le
fait qu'il y avait des on avait pas dit
super profits mais il y avait une
rentabilité à partager entre les
concessionnaires l'État et les usagers
en tout cas qu'il y avait une discussion
à avoir et lors de grandeur c'est à peu
près ça c'est 30-35 milliards donc ça ça
reste ça reste aujourd'hui
en cours de discussion alors après
qu'est-ce que qu'est-ce que peut faire
l'état moi je pense que l'État un moment
donné doit montrer sa volonté et
le fait que les concessionnaires sont
pas tout puissants parce que ils ont eu
un moment donné des contrats que ces
contrats ben ils ont une vie ils ont on
peut les critiquer on peut les critiquer
sur le fond
alors c'est vrai que à l'époque on avait
demandé ici
j'avais demandé à Dominique de Villepin
pourquoi ils avaient pas modifié les
contrats alors lui il m'avait dit ah ben
Lionel josman avait commencé en 2002 à
ouvrir le capital d'autoroute du sud de
la France au privé et donc à partir du
moment où les le capital était ouvert au
privé on pouvait plus modifier
je trouve que c'est un peu court comme
réponse parce que
en réalité comme on relancer un appel
d'offre sur le reste sur la mise sur le
marché du reste on pouvait très bien
dire bah écoutez cet appel d'offre il
est avec des contrats modifiés et puis
on a je pense que c'est à l'époque on a
voulu aller assez vite comme souvent
d'ailleurs il y a beaucoup de décisions
qui se prennent très rapidement et du
coup on prend pas le temps de faire tout
à fond et à l'époque on avait on n'a pas
pris le temps de le faire à fond donc
après en 2015 quand il y a eu le
protocole d'accord qui a été signé par
Emmanuel Macron et Ségolène Royal
Ségolène Royal qui nous a dit qu'elle
n'avait pas
elle n'avait pas connaissance du contenu
du protocole avant de le lire dans la
presse en fait elle a signé sans savoir
ce qu'elle signait donc monsieur j'ai
trouvé ça quand même assez assez
aberrant mais dans ce protocole d'accord
il y avait quelques petites
modifications du contrat mais à la marge
et notamment par rapport à la
rentabilité la rentabilité si vous
regardez la clause qui est prévue dans
le le code de 2015 sur le entre
guillemets les excès de rentabilité
c'est des c'est des cibles
inatteignables c'est à dire que elles
seront jamais atteintes quel que soit
l'évolution du trafic quasiment c'est
pas possible donc à un moment donné il
faut il faut quand même sérieux discuter
sérieusement ne pas s'en laisser compter
parce que les sociétés concessionnaires
ont tendance effectivement à faire
rapidement du chantage et dire vous
inquiétez pas on va on va aller devant
la justice et vous allez voir ce que
vous allez voir bon c'est vrai qu'en
2015 il y avait eu la décision
inélattérale aussi de Ségolène Royal de
gelée les tarifs de 2015
décisions qui en fait mettait l'état un
petit peu en position de faiblesse dans
la négociation c'était pas simple parce
que là là en l'occurrence elle avait
pris vraiment une décision qui était
absolument pas conforme au contrat et
sans aucune concertation sans rien donc
c'est vrai que alors en plus ça a été
rattrapé c'est que le rattrapage de 2015
ça s'est étalé jusqu'en 2023 c'est à
dire que cette année on paye encore le
rattrapage de 2015 c'est la dernière
année on va payer 2015 et que tout le
rattrapage a été plus important que ce
qu'aurait automobile uniquement en 2015
donc il faut aussi avoir ça en tête
c'est la négociation elle s'est faite
rapidement en début 2015 encore une fois
trop rapidement c'est souvent trop
rapide c'est pour ça que anticiper comme
vous le faites et comme on a essayé de
le faire au niveau de la commission
d'enquête c'est important parce que
c'est important de d'anticiper l'avenir
d'avoir bien conscience de l'ensemble du
sujet et de pouvoir anticiper cela il
s'agit pas pour moi en tout cas
personnellement d'éliminer les sociétés
des sociétés compétentes des sociétés
privées et je ne dis pas qu'elles
doivent pas gagner d'argent parce que
moi je considère qu'une société privée
doit gagner de l'argent c'est normal
sinon il y a plus personne qui va
travailler mais faut que ça soit
raisonnable faut que ça soit raisonnable
et des clauses d'encadrement de la
rentabilité si on disait
on discute on a une clause de revoyure
tous les trois ans par exemple on fait
des contrats de 12 ou 15 ans
je dis ça comme ça mais j'ai même pas
réfléchi à durer mais qu'on se dise tous
les trois ans on se remet autour de la
table et si la rentabilité a varié de
plus ou moins 5 % on regarde les
conséquences et la discussion qu'on peut
avoir c'est des choses qui peuvent tout
à fait s'imaginer c'est pas aberrant et
puis voilà et il gagne correctement leur
vie à 8 % honnêtement c'est c'est bien
gagner sa vie on aimerait tous avoir des
placements à 8% bon
voilà et après la durée des contrats
dépendra effectivement des
investissements qu'on leur demandera
aussi parce que forcément si si on
considère qu'il y a beaucoup
d'investissements à faire les contrats
sont plus longs s'il y en a beaucoup
moins ils sont plus courts donc voilà je
sais pas si j'ai répondu un peu à toutes
vos questions j'aurais peut-être oublié
de
le train pour pour financement d'autres
infrastructures alors
alors ce qu'on peut dégager la marge la
marge d'ici 2030 6 c'est 30-35 milliards
c'est ce que je disais après ça c'est la
marge globale dans laquelle il faut
regarder la répartition et la façon
d'affecter la façon d'affecter cet
argent comment il peut remonter et
comment on peut l'affecter au
financement d'autres d'autres
infrastructures de transport ça moi j'ai
pas forcément la réponse là c'est vrai
que c'est une question c'est une
question que je pense que votre
commission doit examinée dans le cadre
de ces travaux essayer de réfléchir à la
façon dont ça peut se faire est-ce que
c'est la création du société spécifique
est-ce que c'est voilà moi je me méfie
toujours la création de structure
supplémentaire je l'ai dit à Olivier je
suis toujours un peu parce que les
structures supplémentaires c'est souvent
des coûts supplémentaires donc il faut
il faut toujours un peu se méfier de ça
ceci étant s'il y a une vraie
justification et un vrai intérêt pour
pour l'État et pour la collectivité
publique pourquoi pas à demander voilà
voilà il paye pas la fuite maintenant
maintenant voilà la contribution la
contribution volontaire qu'on a qu'on a
inscrite moi je comprends même pas qu'on
est inscrit ça comme contribution
volontaire j'aurais dit c'est une
contribution c'est tout il y a pas de
volontariat vous avez de l'argent vous
contribuez et puis c'est tout allez dire
c'est volontaire
là maintenant si juridiquement il se
base sur le truc c'est volontaire nous
si on veut plus on veut plus
ça marche pas comme ça
au niveau des
un petit peu sur les relations qu'on
peut avoir avec les concessionnaires et
les négociations alors c'est pas simple
mais sur le contrôle des concessions il
y a eu un avant 2015 et un après 2015 la
création de la RT est un point très
positif et finalement je pense que les
concessionnaires à l'époque étaient
assez hostile à la création de cette
autorité et pourtant ils l'ont accepté
et sur le contrôle effectivement des
concessions on voit un progrès donc il y
a des évolutions possibles faut pas
comme le dit Vincent faut pas être
résigné et se dire on peut rééquilibrer
le rapport de force entre les
concessionnaires et sans sans jeter le
propre sur le sur les grandes sociétés
autoroutières il est c'est pas le c'est
pas le sujet parce que nous avons quand
même on constate que nous avons des
autoroutes à un niveau très acceptable
enfin mode de bonne qualité ils ont fait
comme dit le rapport ils font leur
travail mais quand même au détriment de
la du pouvoir des pouvoirs publics c'est
clairement avec une rentabilité qui
n'est pas à notre sens acceptable
merci on va prendre toutes les questions
là parce que sinon on arrivera pas
arrivera pas dans le temps
pour le groupe socialiste écologiste et
républicain Hervé gilet
merci président ce Président chers
collègues sur le rapporteur je vais
essayer de d'approfondir peut-être
certains sujets puisqu'effectivement il
y a déjà des niveaux de réponse qu'on
peut et t'apporter alors bien évidemment
votre de vos travaux ont été
particulièrement précieux puisque les
questions sont encore particulièrement
fortes notamment sur le niveau de
rentabilité et donc sur les bénéfices
aujourd'hui qui apparaissent et
notamment vous avez cité le rapport de
l'IGF qui met qui met en perspective
aussi à un certain nombre de
préconisations genre l'occasion
peut-être aussi d'y revenir mais vous en
avez forcément connaissance je voudrais
peut-être me situer plus dans l'axe
commission aménagement du territoire et
du développement durable alors d'une
part il y a bien sûr préparer la fin des
concessions mais encore faut-il que le
contrôle des travaux nécessaires pour
que le réseau soit bien en état d'issu à
la fin que ces travaux soient
effectivement bien en et bien négocier
quel est le pouvoir aujourd'hui de
vérification de cette situation qui est
quand même un élément qui est quand même
particulièrement important pour la fin
des concessions ce qui m'intéresserait
aussi c'est on parle de de ces moyens
financiers qui pourraient être alloués
mais n'y a-t-il pas aujourd'hui une
réelle opportunité aussi d'engager les
concessionnaires dans des
investissements plus lisibles plus
massifs dans les mobilités durables on
voit qu'aujourd'hui il y a quand même
des niveaux qui sont pas suffisamment
atteints sur le déploiement des bornes
électriques bien sûr mais on voit que on
peut utiliser aussi les délaissés
autoroutiers et la loi accélération des
énergies renouvelables à cibler à un
moment donné justement et à interroger
la capacité aussi des concessionnaires
autoroutiers à promouvoir un certain
nombre de projets j'aimerais avoir votre
avis par rapport à ça vous situiez à un
moment donné vous remettiez en
perspective les travaux les propositions
de notre collègue Olivier Jacquin sont
un syndicat effectivement national en
disant mais oui mais ça va être encore
une nouvelle structure sauf que la fuite
à l'heure actuelle n'est absolument pas
outillée pour jouer le rôle d'un
véritable syndicat au niveau national si
vous le permettez l'expression c'est une
boîte à lettres ni plus ni moins donc ce
n'est absolument pas une structure
qu'elle est compétences suffisantes pour
avoir une vision prospective et de mise
en œuvre d'un certain nombre de projets
au niveau national et se comporter comme
un syndicat donc soit transformer la
flip ce qui pourrait être une chose mais
à ce moment-là on crée une nouvelle
structure donc là il y a quand même une
question de fond qui est posée sur ce
sujet là et si on parle un peu plus
d'aménagement du territoire toujours en
lien avec Olivier Jacquin on peut aussi
s'interroger sur une régionalisation car
après tout aujourd'hui un certain nombre
de syndicats régionaux par exemple je
parle de la nouvelle Aquitaine prenons
cet exemple n'ont pas forcément les
moyens nécessaires de pouvoir
accompagner aussi une politique de
projet à l'échelle régionale et de
l'accompagner en subsidiarité avec
l'ensemble des partis prenantes sur le
plan régional ne pourrait-on pas à ce
moment-là
une part affectée également au niveau
régional ce qui permettrait d'avoir et
de développer une vision d'ensemble sur
des projets qui nécessitent des
complémentarités qui nécessitent des
schémas d'organisation et de
planification donc j'aimerais bien avoir
votre vision à ce niveau là parce que
les besoins sont importants il nous faut
créer des effets de levier de lisibilité
et là on a une réelle opportunité de
pouvoir dans le cadre des procédures de
renouvellement mettre en place les
conditions d'avoir une vision plus
partagée que ça soit au niveau national
et régional vous savez qu'au niveau
régional on peut pas parler aujourd'hui
d'un concept de mobilité si on n'a pas
des schémas de mobilité régionaux
départementaux métropolitains qui soient
vraiment complémentarisé et pour ce
faire les concessionnaires devraient
aussi apporter leur propre vision on
voit aujourd'hui des possibilités de
mettre de réserver par exemple des voix
quand on arrive sur les métropoles avec
des aménagements il n'y a pas de volonté
de un véritable volont arisme à l'heure
actuelle des concessionnaires sur ces
sujets là donc il faut directement les
interpeller qu'en pensez-vous
il chers collègues pour le groupe RDPI
et pour 3 minutes la parole est à
Frédéric marchand merci monsieur le
Président ça prendra moins de 3 minutes
puisque l'essentiel des questions a déjà
été posée les sujets soulevés non
simplement remercions à la fois pour la
clarté et la très belle démonstration
qui a été faite le président et le
rapporteur sur un sujet qui est
aujourd'hui effectivement au coeur de
nombreuses interrogations qui s'agissent
de l'État qui s'agit de la
représentation parlementaire mais qu'il
s'agisse aussi et surtout du
consommateur j'ai envie de dire
d'autoroute un principe de base quand
même c'est de dire qu'on va quand même
des autoroutes qui sont en excellente
étage je pense que ça tout le monde est
d'accord grâce à des grilles tarifaires
qui incitent à l'investissement vous
l'avez dit jusqu'en 2035 c'est à la fois
l'avantage de cette grille de fixation
de tarif qui a aussi un défaut majeur
vous l'avez dit c'est que l'État n'a pas
conservé la possibilité d'ajuster les
tarifs en fonction du taux de rendement
interne actionnaire et ce qui nous
conduit aujourd'hui à cette situation
qui est que si j'ai bien lu
effectivement le rapport avec la
rentabilité des concessions Vinci
Eiffage par exemple soit près du 2/3 du
réseau est évalué 12% contre 7,67
initialement prévue lors de la
privatisation alors on voit bien
aujourd'hui vous l'avez dit qu'il y a
différentes options qui s'offrent à nous
pour éviter que cette exploitation des
concessions autoroutières deviennent une
véritable rente ces raccourcir la durée
des concessions options qui est
juridiquement la plus solide et
économiquement peut-être la plus
prometteuse introduire une clause de
révision des contrats qui permettra
d'introduire une clause de révision du
tarif des péages par les temps en
fonction du taux de rentabilité j'ai
bien compris que ces options étaient
souhaita mais est-ce que vous pensez
sincèrement vous avez abordé le sujet
qu'elle soit réalisable avant la fondée
concession dans le cadre du négociation
ou est-ce qu'il faut nécessairement
attendre la fin des concessions afin
d'introduire ces closer enfin pour
rebondir sur ce que disait à l'instant
mon collègue gilet dans quelle mesure
est-il possible de mieux prendre en
compte les objectifs indispensables
aujourd'hui transition écologique avec
notamment le maillage des bornes de
recharge pour les véhicules également
prendre en compte les voies réservées
notamment tout pour le transport partagé
est-ce que ces critères peuvent selon
vous faire l'objet de négociation ou
doivent-ils être introduits au moment du
renouvellement de la la concession merci
collègue pour le groupe CRCE et pour 3
minutes la parole est à Gérard laek
oui merci merci monsieur le Président
Monsieur le président de la Mission
monsieur le rapporteur merci et bravo
pour les éclairages que vous nous
apportez moi j'ai eu à traiter aussi
quelques petits contrats de concession
dans une vie antérieure et
je n'ai donc pas de
d'hostilité particulière à l'égard du
mode de concessif j'ai compris au
demeurant qu'il faut quand même être bon
en mathématiques
pas trop mauvais endroit et c'est
nécessaire à mes yeux pour élaborer de
bons contrats et pour assurer de bons
suivis
toutefois moi la question que je me pose
c'est la suivante c'est que dans un
contrat de concession
le concessionnaire est réputé porté
quelques risques
c'est un peu fait pour ça tout de même
risque que d'autres ne peuvent pas
assumer c'est l'avantage du modèle
concessif
et
en acceptant donc d'assumer une part de
risques on peut y trouver avantage en
tout cas le concédant est en droit dans
l'obtenir des avantages alors je ne sais
pas si dans votre mission
si vous avez réussi à identifier les
avantages que procurer le modèle ou qui
était censé procurer le modèle j'ai
entendu que les contrats étaient
élaborés de longue date qu'il n'est
qu'ils n'ont pas été infligés mais
peut-être avez-vous au cours de ces
missions
identifier donc l'avantage que procurer
le modèle
et à l'inverse identifié aussi
l'avantage qui n'était pas au
rendez-vous
donc
il me plairait d'en avoir quelques
éclairages parce que dans la séquence
qui va suivre nous aurons sûrement à
interroger nos interlocuteurs quant à
leur bonnes intentions
merci chers collègues pour le groupe Les
Indépendants la parole est à Pierre mais
deviennent
merci monsieur le Président
merci monsieur le Président Monsieur le
rapporteur de la commission d'enquête
pour ces éclairages
je tiens quand même à rappeler que que
ce rapport cette commission pourra
fournir un rapport qui est légèrement
redondant quand même puisque notre
excellente de commission en 2015 avait
fait un groupe d'études sur les
concessions autoroutières dont j'étais
vice-président et qui tombait à peu près
sur les mêmes problématiques puisque les
choses on peut bouger c'était l'époque
de Madame de Madame royol alors c'est
vrai qu'au-delà des mathématiques dans
les mathématiques il y a des plus il y a
des moins je vois il faut le rappeler
comme les périodes de confinement on
était
il y a eu un rapport à charge mais
vraiment à charge de l'Autorité de la
concurrence qui avait d'ailleurs été
dénoncé par plusieurs sénateurs
plusieurs ministres et Ségolène Royal
c'était adjoint les services d'un
cabinet bien nommé qui s'appelait
microéconomique et qui proposait ce
royaume de reprendre les concessions
pour 30 milliards de le revendre pour 50
bon tout ça a été remis à plat en est
tombé sur les à peu près les mêmes
conclusions il fallait 50 milliards pour
reprendre les concessions autoroutières
et pour les remettre en appel d'offres
on n'était pas sûr on est racheté en 50
milliards de trouver des candidats à des
conditions moins avantageuses mais
au-delà des au-delà des chiffres parce
que c'est compliqué le chiffre en
matière de constitution autoroutière il
faudrait réellement expliquer ce qu'est
un modèle de concession en J on ne parle
il faut quand même parler de
l'investissement qui a été fait au
départ évidemment il y a eu 2002 il y a
eu 2005 mais il y a eu une rachat il y a
une reprise de dette donc un
investissement de départ de 40 milliards
à peu près suit une période de déficit
où on arrive au bout de quelques années
à zéro et une période de bénéfice
et en 2000 en 2015
le cabinet microéconomique savait
calculer avait sorti des chiffres de
rentabilité assez aurissant puisqu'ils
arrivaient à calculer la rentabilité à
l'instant T dans les périodes de
bénéfice mais on occulter
l'investissement la reprise de la dette
et les années de déficit donc c'est très
compliqué de calculer surtout que ces
contrats et sont quand même bien ficelés
vous l'avez dit il y a des armées de
juristes et c'est très compliqué à
demander à démonter et très cher par
rapport aux prorogation évidemment c'est
un problème mais à chaque progression
suivent des investissements ou des
engagements que les temps n'avaient pas
tenu et qu'il avait payé sous forme de
porrogation c'est aussi le problème moi
je veux quand même voir le positif c'est
le l'état de nos autoroutes aujourd'hui
c'est un vecteur formidable de tourisme
pour pour notre pays puisqu'on a quand
même les plus belles autoroutes d'Europe
et je me pose des questions au-delà des
reprises première question que je me
pose si on faisait une reprise brutale
c'est la crédibilité de la parole de tu
serais quand même gravement
atteinte deuxième problème négocier je
pense que c'est la solution la
négociation mais il est difficile de
négocier quand on fait passer les
concessionnaires pour des voyous dans la
presse c'est ce qui se fait la presse
est déchaîner contre eux en ce moment
c'est de Bonton de se déchaîner contre
les entreprises qui font des bénéfices
bénéficier record au bénéficions on aura
entendu de tout ils ont été complètement
stigmatisés dans la presse donc je sais
pas si le moment est propice à la
négociation à mon avis il vaut mieux
attendre une accalmie entamer des
discussions avec eux parler des futurs
concessions peut-être parler de
d'aménagement peut-être sur les tarifs
mais pas de cette façon je crois pas
d'une façon aussi brutale
c'est c'est compliqué il est évident que
c'est quelque chose qui rapporte mais il
y a l'état aussi quand même perso
quelques ronde puisque c'est pas le
dernier et à l'époque Dominique Deville
Le Pen avait qui suivait Jospin en 2002
n'avait pas fait une si mauvaise
affaires que ça personne n'en avait crié
au scandale puisque c'était quand même
dégagé une belle manne pour attaquer son
mandat donne-moi les questions que je
pose par rapport à la à l'avenir de ces
concessions si on attend la fin des
concessions si on peut les abréger à
quelles conditions et quel candidat
parce que le problème avait été posé en
2015 et à certaines conditions on savait
qu'il n'y aurait plus de candidats
et
si l'État est obligé de reprendre les
autoroutes comme ça a été évoqué aussi
sur certaines pistes étant sûr que les
recettes se réaffectées aux
investissements et à l'entretien des
autoroutes ça c'est autre chose quand on
connaît la situation budgétaire de notre
pays et dans quel état finirait finirait
nos autoroutes parce qu'on fantasme sur
des recettes je suis pas sûr que l'État
s'y reprenait les autoroutes feraient
les mêmes recettes que des
professionnels qui connaissent
parfaitement leur métier
et enfin pour le groupe geste Jacques
ferrique oui merci merci à vous deux et
à vos collègues pour le travail de cette
commission d'enquête sur le contrôle la
régulation et l'évolution des
concessions je crois qu'effectivement
c'est une mise à plat ça a été dit très
utile et je dirais si ça doit être
ressenti comme une forme de brutalité
par les concessionnaires je dirais une
certaine façon tant mieux parce qu'il y
a de la pression qui est nécessaire pour
rééquilibrer les choses vers l'intérêt
général
alors beaucoup de choses ont été dites
donc j'ai pas je vais essayer d'éviter
de faire trop de redit
la première question c'est sur
effectivement les conditions d'exercice
du travail vous avez eu du fournir et
que les uns et les autres ont fourni que
ça soit la RT l'IGF et puis nous le
Sénat donc sur les conditions pour
suivre réguler essayer de rectifier
l'équilibre économique et financier donc
la surentabilité d'une bonne part des
parce que si j'ai bien compris chacun a
dû un peu inventer sa méthode sa
méthodologie pour mesurer cette
rentabilité actionnaire et quand on voit
les écarts entre les colonnes et les
différents tableaux c'est pas
négligeable donc à votre sens
concrètement qu'est-ce qu'il faudrait
mettre en place
avec ce sacro-saint secret des affaires
pour plus de transparence et clarté
nécessaire au moins pour les
parlementaires dans cette ordre d'idée
qu'elle renforcement de la RT je sais
que la RT souhaiterait que ces avis que
l'État soit lié par ces les avis de la
RT
donc pour les renégociations les
avenants comment faire en sorte que ça
s'effectue dans des conditions moins
déséquilibrées plus satisfaisantes alors
pour les contrats en cours j'ai entendu
ce qui vient d'être dit pour l'essentiel
c'est c'est pas des bons contrats et
leurs conditions de suivi sont pas
bonnes donc comment en quelque sorte
arrêter les frais avant les échéances
pas prévu si c'est possible comment
écourter l'affaire tout en garantissant
effectivement une bonne qualité des
infrastructures un réseau à jour par
rapport à ce prévoyait les contrats et
en bon état alors sur le l'avenir mais
l'avenir c'est dès maintenant c'est pas
simplement en attendant
2031 36 ou je ne sais quoi avec donc
l'expiration qui s'annonce des des
concessions des principales concessions
actuelles on a les péages actuels qui
seront remis en cause de toute façon
d'une certaine façon alors le Conseil
d'orientation des infrastructures
évoquent à règle européenne constante un
risque de réduction des recettes de 50 à
70% c'est ce qui dit ce qui signifierait
autant la charge du contribuable on a
aussi la fin annoncée des moteurs
thermiques qui fait que la TICPE c'est
pas quelque chose de négligeable va
inévitablement s'étioler donc en clair
on a les recettes fiscales liées aux
produits pétroliers qui vont perdre de
leur importance donc la problématique
ça sera donc d'éviter
un paradoxal renforcement d'attractivité
du monde routier donc si on attend
l'issue des contrats si on attend
l'échéance 2035 des fins des thermiques
pour engager la transition de moyens
générée par la route qui irait au rail
on y arrivera pas donc comment faire en
sorte qu'une bonne partie de ces 30 à 35
milliards i Auray même si vous n'avez
pas la réponse précise vous l'avez dit
au moins vous ne permettez de mieux
cerner la question merci merci je vais
donner la parole à Vincent Delaye merci
monsieur le Président je vais faire vite
je suis désolé mais parce que c'est vrai
qu'il y a beaucoup de questions et
beaucoup de sujets différents
notre collègue gilet
vérification des travaux d'ici la fin
des cours sessions je dirais qu'il y a
quand même une amélioration sensible sur
le suivi des travaux par du fait de la
RT notamment depuis 2015
alors est-ce qu'il faut comme le vient
de dire notre collègue Fernique aller
jusqu'à vers un avis conforme de la RT
quoi qui s'impose au gouvernement
je suis pas sûr mais en tout cas il faut
au moins que le gouvernement dise
pourquoi il tient pas compte des avis de
la RT quoi c'est toujours pareil il
faudrait au moins qu'il y ait une
justification qui soit donnée un
argumentaire qu'on puisse qu'on puisse
entendre ou pas entendre d'ailleurs mais
critiquer ou pas mais en tout cas qu'on
ait quelque chose parce que là on a
l'impression que de temps en temps le
gouvernement ne tient pas compte des
avis de la RT sans dire pourquoi donc il
y a un moment donné il faut
effectivement savoir alors les
investissements effectivement et ça a
été ça a été souligné à plusieurs
reprises il y a beaucoup
d'investissement dans les mobilité
durable
je pense moi que ça peut être imposé au
concessionnaires aujourd'hui dans le
cadre de leur contrat actuel et sans
modifier son projet sans quoi que ce
soit compte tenu des 30-35 milliards il
y a moyen de négocier et notre collègue
médiéviel qui me disait qui disait
est-ce qu'on peut négocier est-ce qu'on
stigmatiser les sociétés
on les stigmatise pas trop mais moi je
pense que les sociétés d'autoroute non
mais elles ont intérêt elles ont intérêt
à discuter et pour l'instant elle
discute rien dans notre commission notre
commission honnêtement c'était de la
langue de bois l'absence de transparence
totale on les a auditionnés moi je les
ai auditionnés même personnellement dans
mon bureau honnêtement on a du mal on a
du mal à obtenir et je pense que elles
ont tort je leur ai dit d'ailleurs je
leur ai dit elles ont tort elles font un
raisonnement à court terme aujourd'hui
elles sont assis sur un super contrat
qui est en fait c'est des contrats qui
ont été conclus entre l'État et lui-même
donc quand on conclut un contrat avec
soi-même on le fait pour la forme on le
fait pas forcément pour le fond et là
elles sont pas du tout adaptées à une
relation normale avec une société privée
alors elle s'assoit dessus elle
considère que si on touche le moins la
moindre virgule ça y est on touche au
contrat donc il y a un moment donné où
c'est pas possible comme cela et ça fait
des années qui font ça donc en fait leur
stratégie aujourd'hui c'est de dire on
encaisse l'argent et on attend 2036 ou
2031 pour ceux qui et je pense pas que
ça soit une bonne façon de faire donc
attendre un peu plus on peut toujours
attendre un petit peu plus mais à quel
moment moi ma stratégie c'est plutôt de
leur mettre la pression et je pense que
la bonne stratégie c'est plutôt de leur
mettre la pression leur montrer que la
puissance publique a aussi alors elle a
une crédibilité elle a des engagements à
tenir mais elle a aussi des fonds
d'intérêt général elle défend pas
l'intérêt privé de tel ou tel elle
défend l'intérêt général et l'intérêt
général c'est de se dire comment on fait
en sorte de garder des bonnes autoroutes
des autoroutes qui se qui se modernisent
qui tiennent compte effectivement de des
plans de mobilité durable peut-être
d'une régionalisation d'une région de de
choses que c'est à ça qu'il faut
réfléchir de quelle façon on peut y
arriver quelle façon on peut le faire
prendre en compte mais tout cela c'est
c'est un équilibre d'ensemble qu'il faut
absolument trouver et pour le trouver
pour le trouver il faut avoir et moi je
leur ai demandé vous pourrez leur
demander aux sociétés d'autoroute
puisque vous avez les auditionner vous
leur demandez quel est l'équilibre
économique et financier des contrats
demandez-leur et vous me direz si vous
avez une réponse moi je serai je serai
je serai preneur si vous donner réponse
il ne s'engage sans rien du tout il dit
simplement la rentabilité on la verra à
la fin du contrat ben non non si on
attend la fin du contrat c'est terminé
il y a plus rien à discuter donc à un
moment donné aujourd'hui je pense que la
pression elle est sur un peu plus sur
elle tant mieux moi je pense qu'elles
ont intérêt à raisonner plus à long
terme qu'à court terme aujourd'hui elle
résonne un peu trop à court terme en
disant ben on encaisse on encaisse nos
dividendes on encaisse nos résultats
c'est très bien mais le raisonnement à
long terme est important pour elle parce
que on a des sociétés de qualité ça
serait dommage de s'en priver
je crois que c'est c'est Pierre qui
disait est-ce qu'il y aurait d'autres
candidats bien entendu dans sa contrat
de concession il faut pas mettre des
conditions telles que on a plus de
candidats un contrat de concession il
sert à quoi et ça c'était pour répondre
je crois
à notre collègue marchand non ou la haie
c'est là qui demandait les avantages les
avantages c'est effectivement
de prendre un certain nombre de risques
pour le compte de la collectivité
publique mais aussi d'investir à mon
délai la collectivité publique elle peut
pas investir et on peut faire investir
par une société privée en disant ben
elle va s'y retrouver va se faire
rémunérer et c'est ça en fait l'avantage
de la concession et honnêtement l'État a
pas montrer des qualités de
gestionnaires dans beaucoup de domaines
exceptionnel donc à partir à partir de
là on peut se dire pourquoi aller
rajouter une gestion entre guillemets
publics et étatique d'un secteur alors
que on a des sociétés qui savent le
faire à condition qu'on les encadre bien
et c'est l'encadrement pour moi qui est
important et l'encadrement le contrat
savoir ce que ce qu'on leur demande et
en fonction de ça voilà et avoir un
partenariat qui soit gagnant-gagnant
parce qu'il s'agit pas d'enfoncer ces
sociétés il s'agit pas des enfoncer ces
sociétés mais il s'agit de les mettre
autour de la table les faire venir
autour de la table parce qu'aujourd'hui
elles viennent pas autour de la table
quand elles viennent autour de la table
c'est avec un avocat et pour dire on va
vous emmener au contentieux donc à un
moment donné c'est c'est pas c'est pas
jouable on l'a vu sur les tarifs les
tarifs effectivement le contrat il
prévoit 70% de l'inflation et c'est une
aberration c'est une libération les
charges des sociétés d'autoroute c'est
30% de leur chiffre d'affaires donc au
minimum ça devrait être au maximum ça
devrait être 30 % de l'inflation parce
que en fait l'inflation elle joue sur
leur charge
elle joue sur leur charge l'inflation et
voilà et aujourd'hui les 4,75% qui ont
été acceptés pour 2023 je l'ai dit ça
fait augmenter les profits des sociétés
d'autoroute de 300 millions par an
300 millions par an donc sur 10 ans ça
vous fait 3 milliards c'est assez simple
donc l'indexation de la tat je dirais
que c'est une routine par rapport à tout
cela donc à un moment donné il faut
quand même revenir à du sérieux à un
raisonnement un raisonnement un peu à
long terme par rapport aux sociétés dans
pierre on aura l'occasion de rediscuter
si tu veux mais moi j'ai aucun souci et
et je tape pas sur les sociétés privées
non non mais Pierre pas du tout pas du
tout je dis simplement que en
l'occurrence en l'occurrence le rapport
normal d'un conséquent avec les
concessionnaires n'est pas respecté moi
j'ai eu l'occasion de gérer des
concessions je regrette le considant il
a aussi des pouvoirs il a aussi des
capacités à faire et il doit pas
simplement dire amen au concessionnaire
voilà alors après
est-ce qu'il faut une nouvelle structure
est-ce qu'il faut un syndicat est-ce
qu'il faut faire évoluer la fuite
moi je ferai plutôt évoluer la feat
j'aurais plutôt tendance à dire on a on
a une agence ben voilà faisons-la
évoluer en fonction de ce qu'on a envie
elle existe déjà on se dit tiens on va
la pousser et elle peut bénéficier de
contributions qui soient pas volontaire
mais qui soit obligatoire contribution
obligatoire et puis voilà on dit vous
contribuez obligatoirement à une agence
de financement des infrastructures de
transport et ça nous permet de nous y
retrouver
[Musique]
voilà j'ai essayé de
alors peut-être que pour notre collègue
thermique la méthodologie sera
rentabilité je l'ai dit rapidement tout
à l'heure mais
on a défini une méthodologie rentabilité
sur la rentabilité actionnaire elle a
été reprise par l'Inspection générale
des finances elle est validée entre
guillemets par l'Inspection générale des
finances la RT fait un autre type de
calcul et j'aimerais avoir la
transparence de son calcul moi je dis à
la RT je leur ai dit d'ailleurs quand on
est allé sur place parce que moi j'ai
passé une journée à la RT je leur ai dit
moi je comprends rien à votre calcul
j'aimerais avoir les éléments qui me
permettent de le vérifier et une fois
qu'on l'a vérifié on dit comprendra
mieux et on maintenant j'ai bien compris
la différence avec la nôtre moi je
considère que notre méthode est
meilleure et en tout cas montre mieux la
rentabilité réelle
alors vous avez abordé un point sur la
réduction liée à l'Europe au règlement
européen ça c'est un vrai sujet qu'il
faut approfondir et je pense que votre
commission peut l'approfondir un petit
peu pour savoir ce qui va se passer
parce que il y a eu effectivement un
accord au niveau européen entre suite à
la contentieux entre les Autrichiens et
les Allemands et ils ont fini par dire
on peut plus on peut plus prendre de
péage mettre de péage si on a amorti
toutes les infrastructures quelque chose
comme ça je le dis rapidement et façon
succincte mais en tout cas c'est un
sujet qui mérite d'être un peu creusé
parce que sinon il faut intervenir au
niveau européen pour éviter cela moi je
considère que il faut pas qu'il y ait
plus de péage les autoroutes gratuites
c'est c'est complètement c'est à mon
avis c'est pas une bonne solution il y a
quelques pays qui l'ont qui l'ont fait
et en fait on fait pas et nous on est un
pays qui est beaucoup traversé on a
beaucoup de véhicules étrangers qui
traversent la France si on se dit bah on
leur fait plus payer les autoroutes ah
bah voilà on en a plus de contribution
d'une bonne partie des des personnes qui
traversent et en plus on favoriserait
l'utilisation des voitures donc c'est
pas c'est pas l'objet aujourd'hui
l'objet aujourd'hui c'est d'arrêter
d'augmenter de façon à considérer les
autoroutes parce que je considère que
les augmentent de façon à considérer et
de récupérer une partie de ces sommes là
pour faire autre chose peut-être avec
une transformation de la fuite je
m'excuse on est on est très très rapide
mais comme on doit aller en commission
des finances sinon on va être sanctionné
financièrement
c'est embêtant merci merci je crois que
je crois que ce débat est un est
intéressant et je crois que le fait
d'avoir engagé cette ce débat au sein de
la commission d'aménagement du
territoire et quelque chose de
fondamental parce que effectivement
comme on le dit il y a des choses qui
nous conviennent bien des choses qui
conviennent moins bien que comme on peut
utiliser les choses et puis je crois
qu'il y a un sujet qui va falloir quand
même que l'on évoque c'est c'est la
décarbonation des autoroutes c'est quand
même un sujet important et bien encore
merci à la commission d'aménagement du
territoire d'avoir lancé ce débat et
effectivement d'entendre des
concessionnaires comme ça pour aussi
leur poser un certain nombre de
questions et puis et puis merci à vous à
vous deux merci monsieur le Président
merci monsieur le rapporteur et bonne
réunion à la commission des finances
vous dites que c'est un petit break là
on va faire un petit break en attendant
que Monsieur Copé arrive on est prévu
s'il est là on va commencer tout de
suite
bien
monsieur le Président
mes chers collègues
nous poursuivons notre cycle d'audition
consacrée à l'avenir des concessions
autoroutières en accueillant Monsieur
Pierre Coppet président de Vinci
Autoroutes qui est le premier
concessionnaire autoroutier français
avec un réseau de plus de 4400 km sur
les plus de 9000 km d'autoroute concéder
je rappelle à titre liminaire que le
principe des contrats de concession
consiste à confier un tiers en
l'occurrence des sociétés
concessionnaires d'autoroute le
financement la conception la
construction l'entretien l'exploitation
et la maintenance des autoroutes pour
une durée prédéfinie et de leur faire
supporter les risques associés en
contrepartie du droit pour les SCA
percevoir un pH
alors que ce profil dans les prochaines
années la fin des contrats de concession
autoroutier notre commission a pour
ambition à travers nos auditions
d'anticiper cet échange majeur pour la
politique routière française et à faire
en quelque sorte le bilan des
concessions tel qu'elles ont été pensées
mises en oeuvre jusqu'à présent dans
cette perspective je souhaiterais vous
interroger sur quatre points monsieur le
Président ma première question est de
nature plutôt prospective en tant que
premier concessionnaire autoroutier de
France comment appréhendez-vous la fin
des contrats de concession comme en
anticipez-vous je souhaiterais en
particulier savoir dans quelle mesure et
comment vous préparer à la restitution
des biens
où en sont les inventaires des biens de
retour et la définition d'une doctrine
quand on bon état cible de ses biens
ma seconde question porte cela ne vous
étonnera pas sans doute sur la
rentabilité et concession sujette à de
nombreux commentaires
plusieurs rapports récents notamment
celui d'inspection générale des finances
qui a récemment fuité dans la presse
tant à montrer que certaines SCA ont des
taux de rentabilité interne bien
supérieur à ce qui était prévu par les
contrats de concession certains sujets
d'étudier l'opportunité de raccourcir la
durée de certains contrats Bruno Le
Maire a indiqué et vouloir saisir le
Conseil d'État sur cette question que
répondez-vous à de tels discours et
propositions
j'en viens à ma troisième question qui
porte quant à elle sur la fiscalité des
autoroutes la première ministre a évoqué
l'idée de faire davantage contribuer le
secteur autoroutier au plan d'avenir
pour les transports et notamment en
faveur du monde ferroviaire quel regard
portez-vous sur cette proposition je
rappelle que les sociétés
concessionnaires d'autoroute remettent
en cause depuis 2021 le versement de la
contribution volontaire exceptionnelle à
l'Agence de financement des
infrastructures de transport Lafitte
compte tenu de l'indexation de la taxe
d'aménagement du territoire sur
l'inflation faut-il s'attendre à une
réaction similaire si d’éventuelles
nouvelles taxes étaient prévues les
discussions avec le gouvernement ont
déjà et ont-elles déjà été engagés sur
ce point enfin pouvez-vous évoquer
quel moyen sont consacrés à la
décarbonation des autoroutes avez-vous
estimé les besoins d'autant la matière
avant de vous céder la parole pour une
durée de 10 minutes au maximum je
précise que nous avons fait le choix
d'entendre un grand nombre d'acteurs ce
qui a pour conséquence
de limiter à 1h15 pour chacun des
auditions de la matinée
je voudrais le nom je vous demanderai
donc de respecter le temps de parole car
de la manière même manière en plein
accord avec les chefs de fil de chaque
groupe nous avons convenu qu'un seul
orateur par groupe politique
interviendrait disposerait de 4 minutes
pour le groupe républicain et socialiste
écologique est républicain 3 minutes
pour les autres groupes hormis le groupe
Union centriste puisque j'ai ouvert les
débats monsieur le Président venant la
parole merci monsieur le Président je me
réjouis que vous vous intéressiez à ce
sujet de la préparation de l'échéance
des contrats de concession
autoroutières d'abord parce que il se
dit beaucoup de choses sur les
concessions d'autoroute ces derniers
temps et ensuite car la question de la
route est essentielle pour nos
concitoyens aussi bien que pour les
finances publiques au regard des besoins
d'investissement nécessaire qui ne vont
faire que croître du fait de la
nécessité de décarboner les transports
mais aussi du fait des ressources
collectées par la mobilité routière qui
sont appelés à diminuer si rien n'est
fait je voudrais d'abord rappeler
quelques chiffres du côté des parts
modèles la route représentait en 2019
87% des déplacements de personnes en
France cette part est stable depuis 30
ans elle était de 88% en 1990 et
concernant les marchandises la part de
la route en 2021 était de 85% chiffre
constamment croissants depuis que des
statistiques publiques
la part de la route était de 58% en 1984
du côté des investissements dans les
infrastructures de transport ils sont
globalement constants depuis 1990 ils
étaient de 14 milliards en 90 par an
mais il baisse en part du PIB pour ne
représenter que 0,97 % en 2021 là où il
représentait un 25 % en 90 ce qui fait
une baisse relative de plus de 20%. ils
ont été fortement réorientés depuis
quelques années au détriment de la route
qui de 65% des investissements en
tendance de long terme et passer à
45%. c'est 20% d'écart ont globalement
été transféré transférés vers les
transports urbains pour 17% qui sont
passés de 11 à 29% des investissements
et vers le réseau ferré principal dont
la part dans les investissements est
passé de 15 à 19%. du côté des recettes
la route
est fortement contributrice au budget
le public le rendement de la TICPE sur
les carburants et de l'ordre de 33
milliards et le produit des péages
autoroutiers étaient en 2021 d'environ
12,4 milliards d'euros TTC donc
4,7 milliards
d'impôts et taxe ce qui représente près
de 40 % de fiscalité la part hors
fiscalité est intégralement utilisé au
financement des infrastructures
autoroutières et la part fiscale abonde
le budget général mais elle est aussi
pour partie fléchée à hauteur d'un
milliard d'euros pour l'ensemble du
secteur vers les autres infrastructures
de transport par son par l'affectation
au budget de la fift de la taxe
d'aménagement du territoire et de la
redevance de manière
l'autoroute finance donc le ferroviaire
et le record model depuis
95 l'enjeu majeur des politiques de
transport pour les décennies à venir
vous l'avez dit monsieur le Président et
la décarbonation des déplacements le
secteur des transports représente
environ un tiers des émissions de
carbone du pays et c'est le seul secteur
dont les émissions n'ont pas baissé
depuis 30 ans
84% de ses émissions proviennent de la
route et près du quart proviennent des
seules autoroutes les VL et les PL
contribuant pour départ sensiblement
égal sur autoroute la stratégie
nationale bas carbone prévoit dans le
scénario qui nous permet d'atteindre les
objectifs de la France en termes de
carbone une part modèle de la route de
79,5% en 2050 pour le transport de
personnes là où on est avec un
objectif intermédiaire de 82 4 ans en
2030 et de 85 0
85,3% en 2050 pour le transport de
marchandises avec un objectif
intermédiaire de 86,2 en 2030 et dans le
cadre de la révision en cours de la
stratégie nationale ba carbone le
nouveau scénario rehausse fortement
l'ambition de transfert model en
prévoyant une part modèle de la route de
714% en 2050 pour le transport de
personnes et de 71% en 2050 pour le
transport de marchandises et on le voit
quel que soit les scénarios quel que
soit les scénaris pardon la part de la
route sera et restera prépondérante en
2030 et en 2050 et pour atteindre les
objectifs de décarbonation il faudra à
la fois modérer la demande amplifier le
record modèle mais d'abord et avant tout
c'est le levier le plus puissant des
carboné les mobilités routières ce qui
passe par d'importants investissements
alors nous travailler sur ces questions
de comment décarboner la mobilité
routière et avons construit sur ce
terrain un plan en 5 points le premier
point c'est le développement des
infrastructures et des services de
mobilité par partager pour mieux
utiliser la route qui est une
infrastructure existante et qui mérite
d'être optimisé il s'agit de développer
le covoiturage l'épaule d'échanges
multimodaux les quarts express sur
autoroute ou les voies réservées il
s'agit ensuite d'accueillir des
motorisations décarbonées dont notamment
pour les VL se dotés d'un réseau de
bornes de recharge ultra rapide
suffisant pour accueillir une flotte ou
la pénétration du véhicule électrique
est exponentielle je rappelle qu'en 2022
14% des véhicules vendus étaient
électriques et c'est ce qui représente
une part supérieure à la part des
véhicules diesel vendus le troisième axe
c'est de faire de l'autoroute un centre
de production d'énergie renouvelable et
je voudrais de ce point de vue dire ma
déception sur la loi de d'accélération
récemment promulguée elle fera gagner au
mieux six mois sur les quatre ans et
demi qu'il faut en France pour conduire
construire un parc photovoltaïque là où
il ne faut que deux ans en Allemagne et
alors que il faut 6 mois de travaux pour
déployer des panneaux photovoltaïques
qu'il me semble qu'on aurait gagné à les
déployer rapidement et de façon
volontariste sur l'ensemble des axes de
transport linéaire je pense aux délaissé
ferroviaire ou au délaissé autoroutier
le quatrième max c'est les efforts de
fluidification du trafic par
l'innovation et la promotion à la fois
des véhicules autonomes et connectés et
puis par le passage en flux libre au
péage et le cinquième point qui est très
important c'est les efforts
d'investissement pour améliorer la
résilience des infrastructures dans les
milieux naturels il à la fois des forces
sur la biodiversité mais surtout de la
résistance des ouvrages aux incendies ou
aux inondations dont on voit la
multiplication dans la période récente
nous estimons que l'effort
d'investissement sur le réseau
actuellement concédé représenterait
environ 60 milliards c'est un effort
important mais qui ne représente qu'un
tiers de la valeur du réseau concédé
dans les contes de l'État et finalement
il nous faut faire un effort
d'investissement au 21e siècle trois
fois moins important pour décarboner que
celui qu'on fait les générations
précédentes pour construire le réseau
actuel alors il y a bien sûr débat sur
ce montant de 60 milliards et notamment
sur toute la partie d'investissement
qu'il faudrait consentir pour la
décarbonation du transport des poids
lourds notamment parce qu'il y a des
options technologiques et des choix
techniques qui doivent être faits entre
l'hydrogène ou les systèmes de
d'alimentation électrique qui s'agisse
de camions à batterie ou de système
d'induction électrique sur le réseau
autoroutier ou de système de caténaire
et de pantographe et tous ces sujets
sont à la fois au stade expérimental et
au stade de test mais on peut t'attendre
on peut s'attendre à ce qui est une
accélération sur ce sujet notamment
suite à des réglementations européennes
en cours de débat
l'autre point sur lequel vous m'invitez
à m'exprimer et la question des
ressources et je voudrais simplement
dire que les ressources financières
collectées par les mobilités routières
sont appelés à baisser fortement si rien
n'est fait dans les 15 ans qui viennent
le rendement de la TICPE est d'abord
menacé par la transformation de du parc
et l'évolution de la flotte automobile
et si aujourd'hui les 33 milliards qui
sont prélevés par la TICPE sur le
carburant ne sont pas transférés sur la
mobilité électrique cela veut dire que
la TICPE verra son rendement baissé de
façon très significative les péages sont
également menacés a priori ils n'ont
plus de raison d'être
au lendemain de la fin d'une concession
puisque l'infrastructure est amortie et
les près de 5 milliards d'euros de
fiscalité prélevées chaque année
disparaîtront de la même façon si rien
n'est fait certes de nouveau pH pourrait
être instauré dans le cadre de la
directive Eurovignette leur composante
principale la redevance d'infrastructure
doit au plus couvrir les coûts or
l'infrastructure a été amortie à
l'occasion de la première concession et
cette redevance serait alors nettement
plus faible et ce d'autant qu'elle n'a
pas vocation à couvrir de la fiscalité
spécifique on ne peut pas lui adosser la
redevance de manielle ou la tête
si j'ai bien compris la directive
Eurovignette et l'objet premier de cette
directive est d'ailleurs d'éviter que
les pays de transit n'imposent des
péages ou des vignettes trop élevées au
transporteur d'autres pays on parle de
la liberté de circulation en Europe et
le Conseil d'orientation des
infrastructures à lui-même dit que cette
redevance représentait de à trois fois
moins à horizon visible que les péages
actuels la directive europignac permet
de mettre en place une redevance
d'infrastructures en plus de la
redevance d'infrastructures une
redevance pourquoi externe pour prendre
en compte les externalités négatives
comme les émissions polluantes les
émissions sonores ou la congestion
toutefois d'une part une telle redevance
aurait en droit français une
qualification différente de celle de la
redevance d'infrastructures comme les
péages actuels cette dernière aurait le
statut de redevance pour service rendu
alors que la redevance pour coût externe
ne correspond à aucun service il s'agit
donc d'une taxe qui doit être qui doit
respecter l'égalité devant l'impôt il ne
serait donc pas possible de l'appliquer
aux seules infrastructures en concession
comme le périphérique toulousain ou le
contournement nord d'Angers au motifs
qui sont en concession sans l'appliquer
aussi au périphériques parisiens ou à
l'ensemble des contournements urbains on
voit dès lors que l'absectes
acceptabilité d'une telle taxe ne serait
pas
évidente mais aussi que sa collecte ne
serait pas techniquement aisé puisque
aucun équipement ne le permet
aujourd'hui et d'autre part le rendement
de la redevance pour coup externe serait
inférieur au niveau de la fiscalité
spécifique qui pèse actuellement sur le
secteur et il serait décroissant au fur
et à mesure de la diffusion de véhicules
propres alors à la fin après la fin des
concessions historiques le produit des
faits des péages affectés aux
investissements dans les infrastructures
de transport pour être ainsi baissé de 8
milliards d'euros par an voilà ce que je
voulais dire à titreliminaire monsieur
le Président je vous remercie pour votre
attention et je me tiens ainsi que
Blaise rappeur qui est le directeur
général descota à votre disposition si
vous souhaitez que nous précisions ce
propos liminaire
merci monsieur le Président donc on va
donner à parole je vais faire une sorte
de tourniquet pour donner la parole
différemment tout à l'heure donc la
parole est à Nicole Bonnefoy pour le
groupe socialiste
merci monsieur le Président donc mes
chers collègues monsieur le Président
Copé
VINCI Autoroutes est l'un des principaux
concessionnaires privés du réseau
autoroutier français et à ce titre en
partenaire fondamental de la politique
publique des transports que ce soit dans
la décarbonation ou dans le report modal
vous le savez le réseau autoroutier fait
partie intégrante du patrimoine national
et les Français ils sont très attachés
il n'y a rien de scandaleux à ce que les
sociétés concessionnaires d'autoroute
puissent assurer une certaine
rentabilité cependant lorsqu'il y a une
conjonction d'une sur rentabilité
désormais étayée par un rapport de
l'Inspection générale des finances on
parle tout de même de 55 milliards
d'euros de profits de plus que ne le
prévoyez les contrats initiaux et d'une
augmentation constante des tarifs de
péage il s'agit de s'interroger sur la
plus-value pour l'ensemble des Français
et non seulement pour les actionnaires
aussi comment accueilli vous les récent
déclaration des ministres de l'économie
appelant un raccourcissement des
contrats de concession avant leur
échéance étant donné la surentabilité
des sociétés concessionnaires
d'autoroute en tant que partenaire
êtes-vous prêt à renégocier du point de
vue de l'intérêt général et quels sont
vos propositions en matière de partage
des recettes Clément bonne c'est ainsi
fait l'écho d'une contribution
supplémentaire en direction des sociétés
d'autoroute qui pourraient alimenter les
investissements nécessaires dans le
ferroviaire ou encore l'entretien du
réseau routier non concédé par ailleurs
en tant que concessionnaire vous avez
une responsabilité majeure pour la
décarbonation vous venez de l'évoquer
sachant que vos résultats d'exploitation
sont excessivement bénéficiaires des
résultats qui interrogent la récente
augmentation des péages de près de 5%
qui dans la période d'inflation que nous
connaissons paraît peu ou pas justifié
quand l'autorité de régulation des
transports reconnaît elle-même que les
recettes augmentent plus vite que les
charges phénomène amplifié par les
baisses d'impôts de production décidé
sous ce quinquennat la question de la
répartition de la charge du pH entre les
usagers me semble déterminantes pour
l'avenir de la route car le signal prix
pourrait permettre à la fois de prendre
en compte une tarification sociale les
véhicules plus ou moins polluants les
problématiques de congestion
l'optimisation de l'usage de
l'infrastructure ou encore les
transports alternatifs à l'auto-solisme
comment VINCI Autoroutes envisage une
digestion dynamique des pays des péages
dans sa globalité et plus
particulièrement en direction du trafic
poids lourd qui pourrait régler certains
engorgements comme celui de la rocade
bordelaise et vous savez mon engagement
sur le sujet le 31 janvier dernier vous
avez réalisé un colloque intitulé La
Route grande impensée de la transition
écologique démontrant la nécessité de la
décarbonation des infrastructures
routières nous le savons bien les
transports sont le premier poste
émetteur de gaz à effet de serre vous
l'avez rappelé l'autoroute représente à
peu près 7% des émissions de CO2 pour le
pays 54% provient des véhicules
particuliers 25% des véhicules poids
lourds 21% des véhicules utilitaires
légers le plan de décarbonation de Vinci
Autoroutes s'appuie notamment sur une
étude dirigée par le professeur Pierre
geoffronte estimant entre 60 et 70
milliards d'euros les investissements
nécessaires pour faire de l'autoroute
une infrastructure bas carbone à
l'horizon 2030 j'aurais aimé savoir si
cette étude commandée par Vinci qui
engage le réseau concédé sur le long
terme avait fait l'objet d'un contrôle
ou d'une appréciation particulière par
le ministère de la transition écologique
ou d'une agence de l'État tel que
l'ADEME ou encore des collectivités
locales impactées par ce plan leurs
analyses seraient d'autant plus requises
qu'elle permet très d'évaluer les
différents postes d'investissement tout
en les croisant avec d'autres données ou
hypothèse de décarbonation massive comme
la réduction de la vitesse kilométrique
il est selon moi fondamental que les
collectivités nationales et
territoriales concernés est un droit de
regard sur des questions relevant de
leurs compétences en matière de
planification écologique et également en
matière d'aménagement du territoire je
vous remercie pour votre écoute et vos
réponses
je vous remercie 57 c'est bien je vous
remercie madame pour cette question j'ai
commencé par
la dernière remarque
vous voulez répondre à celle-ci puis
après on enchaînera répondez à celle-ci
et ben répondez à celle-ci et puis on va
et après on va enchaîner je voudrais
simplement dire sur ce sur ce dernier
point madame que
il y a dans cette salle de nombreux élus
locaux que je connais et avec lesquels
j'ai eu maintes occasion et vous en
faites partie de concertation sur des
projets sur des aménagements sur des
plans d'investissement et je
souscris à votre remarque sur
l'importance de la concertation locale
je rappelle que nous sommes
régis par un ensemble de procédures et
d'enquêtes publiques qui le rend
obligatoire mais que nous avons par
ailleurs le souci de la concertation et
de l'écoute à la fois des territoires et
de leur représentants et donc je voulais
commencer par dire combien je souscris à
cette remarque monsieur le sénateur vous
motorisez à répondre à l'ensemble de la
question alors vous vous m'interrogez et
figurez-vous que sur la question de la
rentabilité des concessions et des
différentes déclarations qui ont été
faites dans la période récente sur sur
ce sujet alors
je voudrais d'abord dire que cette
question
a déjà été abondamment discuté dans
cette enceinte
en 2014 et 2015 et qu'elle a conduit le
législateur
a confié à l'Autorité de régulation des
transports on a transformé la RAF en
arts à faire puis en art en lui confiant
la mission de surveiller année après
année l'évolution du niveau de
rentabilité des concessions d'autoroutes
la RT c'est saisi de cette question avec
beaucoup de sérieux et elle a produit
deux rapports j'imagine que vous en avez
pris connaissance un qui est sorti en
novembre 2020 et un qui est sorti en
janvier 2023 l'un et l'autre de ces
rapports repose sur un travail qui a le
mérite de prendre en compte l'ensemble
du sujet les concessions d'autoroute se
sont des sujets très capitalistiques
très compliquées et très ancien et donc
pour porter un jugement
valable sur la question de la
rentabilité il faut à la fois regarder
les contrats regarder les modèles et
faire des hypothèses la RT a regardé les
contrats regarder les modèles et fait un
ensemble d'hypothèses qu'elle a partagé
avec les sociétés concessionnaires les
hypothèses de quoi on parle quel est le
plan d'investissement quels sont les
hypothèses de trafic quels sont les
hypothèses de financement quelles sont
les hypothèses d'inflation avec ça on
fait tourner un modèle on reprend
le schéma tel qu'il était lors de la
privatisation en 2002 et le ce qui est
réalisé et puis on regarde la
perspective d'ici à la fin de la
concession alors c'est extrêmement
compliqué puisque il est possible de
mesurer la rentabilité d'un
investissement à la fin
pour faire une mesure intermédiaire il
faut faire toutes sortes d'hypothèses
sinon on raconte n'importe quoi et la RT
a fait ce travail et elle a conclu à
deux reprises j'imagine qu'elle a été
auditionnée dans cette maison elle a
conclu à deux reprises que le taux de
rentabilité des concessions d'autoroute
tel qu'il pouvait être évalué à date
c'est à dire tel que on peut le projeter
à la fin de la concession était cohérent
avec ce qui avait été modélisé
lors de lors de la privatisation donc
pour moi le travail sérieux qui a été
fait sur ce sujet a été fait par la RT
avec des modèles dont chacun connaît les
hypothèses maintenant vous m'interrogez
sur les différentes déclarations qui ont
été faites concernant un rapport de
l'Inspection générale des finances alors
ce rapport a été
diffusé par la presse et donc on a pu en
prendre connaissance je voudrais d'abord
dire que c'est un rapport qui a deux ans
et demi et que c'est un rapport qui a
été commandé par l'État dans le cadre
d'un contentieux entre l'État et les
sociétés d'autoroute sur la compensation
de la taxe d'aménagement du territoire
enfin de l'augmentation qu'on a un
proprement appelé l'indexation de la
taxe d'aménagement du territoire sur
l'inflation
c'est indexation revenait à un
prélèvement de l'ordre d'un milliard
d'euros à l'époque sur le PNL des
sociétés d'autoroute et elles ont
naturellement
contester cette cette mesure dès lors
que la taxe d'aménagement du territoire
n'était pas compensée dans l'intention
du ministère des Finances alors même que
la loi prévoit que la loi portant
création de la tête et prévoit sa
répercussion dans les tarifs et alors
même que les quatre fois précédentes ou
l'État avait augmenté la taxe
d'aménagement du territoire ça avait été
répercuté dans les péages comme on
atteste les débats parlementaires
d'ailleurs donc un contentieux c'est
noué entre les sociétés concessionnaires
et l'État et le ministère des Finances a
confié à l'Inspection des finances un
rapport qui est un rapport de commande
pour démontrer que la taxe ne devait pas
être compensée
j'en dirai pas plus vous avez ce rapport
et simplement je vais vous dire
deux choses la première c'est que je
vous encourage à aller page 65 de ce
rapport où il est écrit que les écarts
qui ont été calculés par l'Inspection
des finances repose sur un calcul très
hypothétique et doivent être
interprétées avec une grande prudence
c'est pas moi qui le dit c'est
l'inspection des des finances et comme
par ailleurs contrairement au rapport de
la RT je ne connais pas le modèle qui a
été produit pas plus que je ne connais
le modèle qui a utilisé le sénateur de
l'oeil pour donner des chiffres
comparables je ne sais pas dire où est
le l'erreur ou les difficultés ce que je
sais c'est que l'Autorité de régulation
des Transports a fait un rapport et a
fait un travail sérieux que ce travail a
été diffusé et qu'il est accessible à
chacun et que ce rapport qui est à la
fois transparent puisqu'on connaît le
modèle
et que il a été euh il a été challengé
sur sur ces hypothèses conclut qu'il n'y
a pas de de difficulté voilà ce que ce
que je peux répondre tout en étant
parfaitement lucide sur le fait que le
débat sur la rentabilité des sociétés
concessionnaires d'autoroute ne repose
de moins en moins sur des considérations
objectifs et que on est bien souvent
dans des débordements passionnels et
j'en appelle simplement au fait que une
concession c'est un contrat dans lequel
il y a des obligations et des
compensations avec un modèle dans lequel
il y a des hypothèses que ce l'ensemble
de ces éléments sont suivis à la fois
par le ministère des Transports le
Conseil d'État et l'Autorité de
régulation des transports et que si vous
interrogez l'ensemble de ces
institutions elle considère que nous
sommes tout à fait dans le cadre
de ce qui a été prévu dans le dans le
contrat
je sais bien que les montants qui sont
en jeu
surprennent mais au risque de vous
étonner le profit qui est aujourd'hui
fait par la Société des Autoroutes du
Sud de la France est à peu près cohérent
plutôt même un peu inférieur à ce qui
était prévu dans le modèle alors il est
très important parce que une concession
c'est un instrument de financement et
que c'est une société à durée déterminée
durée pendant laquelle on est réputé
remboursé l'investissement initial au
début on perd de l'argent c'est la
fameuse courbe en J au début on perd de
l'argent et à la fin on gagne dans les
profits des dernières années de la
concession de quoi compenser les
investissements initiaux on est
exactement dans les termes du modèle tel
qu'il avait été contractualisé au moment
de la privatisation alors quand on
affiche des chiffres à 90 on se dit ouh
là c'est ce sont des montants très
significatifs
je confirme que ce sont des montants
très significatifs mais les montants qui
ont été investis et que les profits
d'aujourd'hui qu'on pense sont très
significatifs aussi
merci alors on va prendre
un orateur par groupe je vais donner la
parole maintenant au groupe RDPI à
Michel Dagbert
et puis après on finira et puis après
vous répondrez globalement
merci monsieur le Président Monsieur le
Président très heureux de vous entendre
aujourd'hui
je suis membre de j'ai été membre de la
commission d'enquête sur les concessions
autoroutières et également membre d'une
commission d'enquête sur la qualité de
nos infrastructures ouvrages d'art à ce
titre je souhaite vous interroger sur la
question de l'entretien de ces
infrastructures les sociétés
concessionnaires sont en effet
contractuellement tenus d'effectuer
l'entretien des voies et des ouvrages
d'art qui leur sont concédés elles ont
ainsi l'obligation de réaliser un
certain volume de travaux les
concessionnaires doivent investir
jusqu'à la fin des contrats afin de
remettre en bon état l'ensemble de
l'infrastructure or en décembre 2022
l'Autorité de régulation des transports
dont on vient d'entendre que vous dites
grand bien sur la qualité du travail
quel produit a publié un document très
critique face aux pratiques observées
lors de la passation des marchés de
travaux de fournitures et de services
mais également lors de la passation des
contrats de sous concession la RT rappel
l'importance de disposer de règles
claires sur le calcul de la valeur
estimée d'un marché de travaux et le
choix de la procédure d'appel d'offres
or elle note aussi le taux très
important notamment pour votre groupe
d'attribution de marchés de travaux aux
sociétés liées capitalistiquement à
votre groupe ASF copyrout Escota ont
ainsi passé près de 50% de leur marché
auprès des sociétés du groupe Vinci elle
émet donc des certaines réserves sur le
coup de certaines opérations de travaux
et beaucoup regrettent en effet le
manque de transparence sur les coûts et
les prix pratiqués lors de la
réalisation des travaux d'entretien de
l'infrastructure
pouvez-vous nous fournir quelques
éléments d'appréciation sur ce point et
nous dire où vous en êtes dans la
réflexion sur la mise en oeuvre de
passation plus transparente dans leur
règle d'attribution merci beaucoup
merci chers collègues pour cette
question pour le respect du temps la
parole est à Gérard Elec pour le groupe
C merci monsieur le Président Monsieur
le Président merci merci de vous livrer
à cet exercice dans un contexte
compliqué de tension fait de tension
diverses d'emblée je voudrais vous dire
ici que je n'ai pas d'hostilité
particulière à l'égard du modèle
concessif je l'immense avantage
d'ailleurs d'avoir contribué à enseigner
quelques-uns avec votre groupe
et d'autre part je précise ici que je
viens de Bretagne et donc comme vous
je partage l'attention particulière que
vous les Bretons à l'existence des
routes et de leurs autoroutes d'ailleurs
quand on l'oublie il ne manque pas de
nous rappeler des choses
donc voilà alors certes il s'écrit
beaucoup beaucoup de choses
dans le contexte actuel et nous ne
pouvons qu'être attentifs à ce qui se
dit à ce qui s'écrit
et permettez-moi de vous dire ici que
tout le monde n'a pas pour livre de
chevet le rapport de la RT
ce qui ne simplifie évidemment pas
évidemment ça ne veut pas dire qu'il ne
faillit pas objectiver les choses
mais nous sommes confrontés quand même à
une interpellation par la société
sur
un certain nombre de marges dont on
parle beaucoup la presse d'aujourd'hui
encore un peu humoristique en écrit
d'autres
il y a là-dedans que des parts de vérité
et moi je voulais vous demander tout de
même si vous preniez la mesure
de l'émotion que suscite cette situation
dans l'opinion publique
autrement dit nous sommes en situation
d'obligation de le prendre en
considération je sais que vous êtes
régie que nous sommes régis par le
secret des affaires il ne s'agit pas de
négocier à la place de l'autorité
conséquente et de vous-même mais
il y a un effort à produire pour rendre
les choses acceptables et il me semble
qu'il serait intéressant que vous
puissiez nous donner quelques pistes
quant à vos intentions et quand travaux
disponibilités à faire bouger les choses
dans le sens exceptable donc je parle
dont je parlais à l'instant dans le
limite évidemment de ce que vous pouvez
communiquer
merci merci chers collègues la parole
est pour le groupe Les Indépendants est
affirmée de ville
merci président monsieur le Président
nous allons consacré une partie de la
matinée à faire quelques mathématiques
et j'ai rappelé à cette occasion que
avant le rapport de l'Agence en état
s'il y avait eu un groupe d'études de la
commission d'engagement du territoire
développement durable mis en place en
2015 qui s'était penché sur le même
problème sur la reprise ou pas des
concessions autoroutières on est tombé à
peu près sur les mêmes conclusions en
étudiant les contrats à l'époque les
rapports de l'Autorité de la concurrence
et du cabinet de Ségolène Royal
microéconomiste avait été mis largement
en cause j'étais des rapports carrément
à charge le résultat avait été le même
au niveau médiatique dans la presse et
on se retrouve un peu dans la même
situation dans un contexte un peu plus
particulier contexte de crise de
contexte d'inflation et où on a on a une
fâcheuse tendance
sur les bénéfices des entreprises que
moi personnellement je préfère en France
des entreprises qui font du bénéfice
puisque c'est quand même synonyme
d'investissement et d'emploi derrière ce
dont on a bien besoin si on veut réussir
notre plan de relance économique
moi je note vous avez parlé aussi
monsieur le Président de cette loi
d'accélération des énergies qui étaient
nécessaires mais qui est pas qui est pas
suffisante c'est vrai qu'il y a des on
n'est pas arrivé à des délais
satisfaisants on en arrive pas à se
défaire des liens dans notre
administration et on n'est pas encore
une réactivité à mon avis qui puisse
nous promettre de d'investir en masse
dans ces énergies renouvelables dont
nous avons tant besoin aussi et à cette
occasion je crois nous en avions discuté
c'est vrai qu'on a on a étudié tout un
tas d'éventualités mais on a
occulté je crois superbement les
hectares les milliers d'hectares qui se
trouvent en bord d'autoroute en bord de
voie ferrée en France puisqu'on est allé
chercher des terrains dit dégradés
dans certaines zones du Conservatoire du
littoral et c'est vrai que c'est ces
zones en mode autoroute de voie ferrée
me paraissent plus prioritaire j'en ai
d'ailleurs parlé à la ministre et elle
est d'accord et moi je pense que ça
devrait faire l'objet d'une prochaine
texte sur les énergies renouvelables
feront l'objet de prochaines textes mais
je crois que ça doit se faire peut-être
en concertation avec vous
et
c'est une mine à exploiter oui
et le troisième sujet c'est on en parle
beaucoup moi c'est vrai que je suis très
intéressé bien sûr par l'avenir de des
autoroutes de à ce qui reste dans le
même état et par la décarbonation des
transports Je travaille actuellement
pour une mission pour l'OPEX sur la
décarbonation de l'aviation mais c'est
vrai qu'il y a pas que l'aviation il y a
la décarbonation des transports routiers
et je crois que vous avez des projets
d'avenir dans ce domaine puisque les
autoroutes représentent une part quand
même non négligeable de des émissions de
carbone de nos transports c'est la
principale donc est-ce que vous pouvez
nous dire deux mots de ces projets de
ces futurs investissements merci
merci chers collègues la parole est à
Jacques ferrique
oui merci
merci monsieur le Président de répondre
à vos questions pour essayer de mieux
cerner les enjeux majeurs pour pour
l'avenir des autoroutes et y répondre
alors il y a évidemment l'enjeu de la
nécessité d'infrastructures modernes en
bon état à jour par rapport à ce qui est
défini dans les contrats et
nouvel enjeu qui s'y rajoute sur la
qualité des infrastructures résilientes
face aux changements climatique je crois
qu'on mesure pas encore tout à fait
correctement aujourd'hui combien les les
conditions climatiques seront
impactantes et combien nos réseaux sont
vulnérables nos modes de transport aussi
l'enjeu de de l'intérêt général qui qui
n'est pas compatible même c'est pas
toujours facile à entendre avec une
surentabilité excessive des
concessionnaires privés je crois que
quand l'équilibre de rentabilité est
globalement atteint
2023 2024 pour une concession amenée à
durer quand même plus longtemps il y a
un problème et il y a un problème si
entre
les actionnaires l'État et les usagers
ce sont surtout les actionnaires qui ont
profité et puis il y a le bon sur
l'enjeu de la décarbonation qui
nécessite vous l'avez dit une mutation
rapide de l'électromobilité qui
nécessite aussi de faire évoluer l'usage
de la route augmenter le nombre de
personnes par véhicule pour éviter le
gâchis énergétique optimiser le frais de
routier ça nécessite aussi pour l'avenir
d'investir fortement ça a été suite au
rapport du coi et le discours de la
première ministre vers les modes
durables et particulièrement le rail en
clair faire financer de façon
significative le rail par la route or
vous l'avez dit on risque d'avoir un
avantage concurrentiel renforcé de la
route le COI l'a dit aussi avec les
péages qui sont appelés à bien moins
rapporter avec la fin des solutions et
l'essentiel des infrastructures amorties
et une neurovignette une TICPE qui va
qui va s'étioler ça c'est clair avec la
fin des termites 9 et une Eurovignette
qui n'offre pas de possibilités dans
rapporter autant à moins peut-être
d'élargir son périmètre au-delà des
seuls autoroutes actuellement concédées
nous en Alsace on expérimentera enfin
mettre en place je l'espère sans trop
tarder notre taxe poids lourd
donc
ma question c'est en gros donc comment
effectivement réussir cette
décarbonation des autoroutes et comment
voyez-vous la perspective d'un bien plus
important abondement de la route pour
les investissements des modes durables
et particulièrement le rail
merci
la parole pour les groupes républicains
est à Bruno Belin
merci monsieur le Président je suis le
président Copé j'espère que vous êtes
content d'être devant nous nous on est
content d'être avec vous ce matin 100%
on n'est pas encore convaincu 100% des
sénateurs qui sont devant vous sont des
provinciaux donc on est nous évidemment
complètement acquis à l'idée de
l'utilité des autoroutes pour desservir
les territoires que nous représentons
pour contribuer à leur attractivité à
leur activité économique évidemment à la
mobilité on a toutefois quand même
quelques préoccupations alors vous avez
cru bon répondre tout de suite une
partie de la question de notre collègue
Nicolas Bonnefoy mais
vous avez répondu très partiellement
donc permettez-moi de reformuler un
certain nombre de questions courtes pour
avoir des réponses claires quel est
votre position notamment sur les tarifs
j'ai lu dans Le Parisien pour citer
l'article récemment que les 4,75% qui
ont été programmés d'augmentation
n'était pas satisfaisant pas suffisant
qu'il fallait même bien sûr envisager
peut-être une augmentation plus
importante à venir donc quel est telle
exactement pour confirmer ce papier ou
l'infirmer
deuxième point sur la rentabilité alors
pardon là aussi j'ai pas encore tout
compris vous dites que c'est compliqué
mais avec un petit effort on essaiera de
comprendre vous parlez que c'est
conforme une modélisation mais elle est
basée sur des éléments hypothétiques
vous-même vous citez une courbe en J la
barre de droite du JM monte haut et vide
par rapport à la début de la courbe donc
il y a eu des propositions très claires
et là j'aimerais commettre votre
position sur la réduction des
concessions la baisse des prix notamment
de certains prix moi je trouve enfin
dans les idées qui sont pas encore
sorties il y a de des échanges ce matin
baisse des prix sur le covoiturage parce
qu'effectivement ça incite à apprendre
en conscience des besoins de
décarbonation des cartes tout ce qui est
effectivement transport en commun
il y a la question de l'état des biens
c'est à dire évidemment
qu'elle est très clairement votre
trajectoire d'investissement ça fait
partie des préoccupations pour les
territoires quel est le bon modèle éco
au-delà de l'échéance comment
imaginez-vous ou comment concevez-vous
la suite alors moi je le dis une fois ce
que j'ai le mot a pas été prononcé
encore depuis 1h48 qu'on est sur le
sujet personne enfin ici en tout cas
dans la majorité de ce de ce Sénat pour
une nationalisation et d'ailleurs je
pense que personne
imagine les capacités de l'État à
répondre à tel objectif mais comment
quelle évolution pour améliorer la
gestion le service rendu et puis dernier
point sur la décarbonations ça a été
abordé pour plusieurs collègues mais là
aussi très concrètement les choses sont
pas dites quel est votre plan pour la
multiplication des bornes électriques
sur le long des autoroutes merci
monsieur le président
merci chers collègues monsieur le
Président coupé je vous propose de
répondre j'aurais simplement une
réflexion à mener sur un sujet qui
préoccupe c'est comment les comment on
met l'ensemble des poids lourds sur les
autoroutes pour éviter que ils
traversent nos villes et nos nationales
et nos départementales alors que ils
encombrent et qui prennent pas les
autoroutes voilà ça c'est une question
en fait je peux commencer par cette
question parce qu'elle est posée à la
fois par
mon collègue alsacien Jacques ferrique
et par Madame Bonnefoy et je pense que
la réponse est assez simple on a à
Strasbourg avec la mise en service de du
grand contournement ouest
vu une interdiction de la route
nationale et de la traversée par les
poids lourds qui a eu un effet
absolument drastique sur la circulation
des poids lourds et donc je pense que
c'est un bête sujet administratif
ou si les collectivités souhaitent que
les poids lourds ne traversent pas les
communes cela relève de décision de
décision préfectorales et on a vu en de
façon très convaincante le l'impact et
l'efficacité de la mesure à Strasbourg
et on est en débat avec Madame Bonnefoy
et avec le préfet
d'Aquitaine sur le même sujet sur la
nationalité c'est le contournement de de
Bordeaux je voudrais répondre à une
question qui vient souvent sur
[Musique]
la transparence vous me dites le rapport
de la RT n'est pas votre livre de chevet
et je comprends que vous préfériez que
vous ayez d'autres choses à faire mais
on peut pas à la fois nous reprocher un
manque de transparence qui est
imaginaire et nous dire qu'on n'a pas le
temps de lire les rapports c'est à dire
que
nous avons communiqué
depuis 2015 tous les marchés d'évoluent
par nos sociétés à la fois l'Autorité de
régulation des transports et au Sénat
la quantité de papier que nous avons
transmis sur notre activité ne tient pas
dans cette pièce et donc je réponds à
votre point sur le la transparence il
n'y a pas de sujet de transparence nous
sommes examinés sous toutes nos coutures
par l'administration par l'Autorité de
régulation des transports par le Conseil
d'État par le juge et par les
commissions parlementaires par la Cour
des comptes et et j'en passe il n'y a
pas de sujet de transparence et il n'y a
pas de question de secret des affaires
nous n'avons rien à cacher simplement
nous sommes gestionnaires
d'infrastructures qui représentent des
montants considérables nous avons pour
le faire des capitaux engagés
considérables et des dettes gigantesques
tout ceci repose sur notre contrat c'est
le seul actif d'une société
concessionnaire et nous sommes toutes
disposés à montrer à communiquer ces
faits ou à expliquer de quoi il s'agit
concernant
l'ensemble des composantes de notre de
notre activité
ensuite vous vous m'avez interrogé sur
les procédures d'attribution des marchés
je vous avoue que
ce sujet
m'étonnera toujours c'est à dire que
nous investissons VINCI Autoroutes
investit de l'ordre de 800 millions
d'euros par an on a une certaine époque
était au-delà de ça au-delà du milliard
par an ça veut dire que ça fait des
milliers de marché tous les ans
l'ensemble de ces marchés nés dévoluent
qu'après un avis
conforme d'ailleurs puisque je l'ai
toujours respecté d'une commission de
marché à laquelle siège la DGCCRF et des
personnalités qualifiées indépendantes
l'ensemble des marchés n'est dévolue
qu'après avis conforme de l'Autorité de
régulation des transports sur les
milliers de marchés que nous avons
dévolu depuis que nous sommes soumis à
ce processus 1 a été deux pardon 2 ont
été contestés par par la RT donc si vous
voulez sur le sujet de la dévolution des
marchés je comprends bien que vous
posiez la question
on parle de volume et de quantité de
procédures qui sont gigantesques encore
une fois tous les marchés sont au Sénat
vous les avez vous pouvez
vous y avez accès et tout ceci se passe
dans une parfaite transparence vous me
posez la question de la part des
sociétés liées du groupe Vinci qui
réaliserait et réalise des travaux pour
pour les sociétés concessionnaires
d'autoroute je voudrais commencer par
dire qu'il y a pas complètement c'est
pas complètement illogique qu'un groupe
de construction soit investi dans les
concessions parce que ce sont des
métiers qui sont assez assez cohérents
et assez compatible et ensuite compte
tenu des procédures et des règles de
concurrence auxquelles nous sommes
soumis la part de marché des sociétés
liées du groupe Vinci dans les travaux
réalisés par les sociétés
concessionnelles à varier elle a été une
époque de 30% elle est fait aujourd'hui
de 50% notamment parce qu'on a réalisé
pas mal de grands travaux il y a
notamment eu l'impact de l'autoroute de
contournement de Strasbourg qui est un
contrat qui a été gagné par un
groupement concessionnaire constructeur
intégré du groupe Vinci heureusement
d'ailleurs sinon je crois pas qu'on
serait jamais arrivé au bout de ce
chantier compte tenu des différentes
difficultés qu'il a rencontrées donc si
vous voulez sur ce sujet
l'accès de des PME à la commande des
sociétés concessionnaires a été posée à
l'époque en 2015 et donc nous avons
d'une part été soumis à des procédures
et à des commissions de marché au
contrôle de la RT et j'avais par
ailleurs à l'époque signé avec le
président de la FNTP un engagement
facilitant le l'accès des PME des
travaux publics au marché des
concessions d'autoroute ce cet engage
cet accord avec entre l'Association des
sociétés françaises d'autoroutes et la
Fédération Nationale des Travaux publics
a fait l'objet d'un comité de suivi qui
a année après année publié un rapport et
publier ses conclusions qui se sont à
chaque fois traduites par insatisfait
site de la FNTP et des petites et
moyennes entreprises sur leur accès à la
commande des sociétés concessionnaires
donc je crois que ce sujet s'il a fait
débat à une époque est aujourd'hui
à mon sens sans problème mais je
n'entends pas de de contestation
là-dessus même si régulièrement on nous
dit ah bah oui mais les concessionnaires
d'autoroute font travailler les
entreprises qui leur sont liées ça n'est
que partiellement vrai et je ne vois pas
le problème que ça pose puisque ce c'est
dans le cadre de procédure transparente
et de mise en concurrence surveillés par
la DGCCRF
alors sur la question de
l'entretien maintenant que vous avez
évoqué et sur le la question de l'état
du patrimoine je voudrais dire quelques
quelques mots qui donnent d'ailleurs je
crois la mesure de de ce dont on parle
sur le seul sujet sur le seul groupe
Vinci autoroute dont j'ai la charge j'ai
par deux vers moi une petite fiche que
je vais trouver sur laquelle figure
l'ensemble du patrimoine que nous gérons
ce patrimoine c'est
4443 km d'autoroute c'est
20.500 km de voix qui représente 112 112
millions pardon de mettre carré de
chaussée c'est 266 heures de repos 180 R
de service 427 échangeurs 48
bifurcations 230 4 gars
6227 ouvrages d'art de franchissement
soit 260 viaducs
2471 passage supérieur
2300 passages inférieurs sans
1194 bus de plus de 2 mètres de diamètre
qui représente une surface de 4 millions
de mètres carrés je le dis parce que
c'est un patrimoine qui est très
important qui représente un montant
d'investissement d'entretien maintenant
moyen de 250 millions d'euros par an et
qui représente un travail de suivi très
considérable j'ai négligé l'essentiel
nous avons 32 tunnels de plus de 300
mètres donc soumis à la circulaire
Mont-Blanc et à l'ensemble des
procédures de sécurité et
1319 ouvrages de sous-trait de
soutènement tout se patrimoine est suivi
de façon très attentive par les services
techniques du ministère des Transports
avec lesquels nous avons des suivis et
des procédures de contrôle de notation
de mesure et de vérification incessantes
et j'ai le plaisir de vous dire que afin
l'état de notre patrimoine était
considéré comme à 97% très satisfaisant
les travaux ou études
des travaux ou des études sur les 3% qui
font l'objet de remarque ou qui doivent
être réparés ou maintenu mais je crois
que nous avons
au-delà des chiffres on le voit très
bien l'état du patrimoine du réseau
autoroutier concédé et meilleur que le
reste du patrimoine routier qui s'agisse
de celui du réseau routier national ou
du réseau départemental ou des
métropoles là où nous sommes notés à 97%
favorables les métropoles sont à 86%, le
réseau routier national est à 86% et les
départements à 89%. donc la vertu du
modèle de la concession c'est aussi de
sanctuariser des recettes et de
formaliser des obligations pour les
exploitants qui assurent un état du
patrimoine qui est je crois jugé
satisfaisant
sur la question du bon état de fin de de
concession cette question est très
régulièrement posée et je crois qu'elle
mérite également
d'être objectivé nous avons sur ce sujet
une obligation qui est écrite dans les
contrats qui est de rendre la concession
et de rendre le patrimoine que je viens
de vous décrire en bon état
ce qui est en débat aujourd'hui c'est la
définition du bon état et dans le cadre
d'un travail qui est très précis qui
fait l'objet de mesures et d'indicateurs
nous sommes en train avec la dgitém et
les services techniques de le Bron de
préciser ouvrage par ouvrage type
d'ouvrage par type d'ouvrage quel est
quels sont les indicateurs permettant de
définir de façon contradictoire entre
l'État conséquent et les sociétés
concessionnelles les indicateurs de
mesure et je crois que ce sujet
satisfait à la fois l'état conséquent et
l'Autorité de régulation des transports
qui
manifesté sur ce sujet des des exigences
régulières
sur la question que vous avez évoqué
monsieur le sénateur du photovoltaïque
et des investissements en matière de
en matière de décarbonation sans les
reprendre tous je pourrais simplement
dire que adapt l'ensemble des aires de
service des sociétés concessionnaires
est équipée de bornes de recharge
électrique ce qui nous préoccupe c'est
que
le dimensionnement actuel des bornes de
recharge électrique correspond à l'état
du parc mais si on extrapole une
progression exponentielle du parc de
véhicules électriques et qu'on veut bien
assimiler le fait qu'il faut 5 à 6 fois
plus de temps pour recharger un véhicule
électrique que pour faire le plein
d'essence il faudrait pour ce
dimensionner à la pointe dans la
perspective d'un parc de véhicules
électriques qui aura atteint les
objectifs qui sont ceux de
l'interdiction du véhicule thermique et
qui sont
qui sont formalisés dans la SNBC il
faudrait
il faudrait installer de l'ordre de 5 à
6 fois plus de bornes de recharge rapide
qu'il n'y a de pompe à essence sur le
réseau ce qui représente un gros
investissement en génie civil mais ce
qui représente aussi toutes sortes de
questions de raccordement et d'amener de
puissance sur les autoroutes ce sujet
fait l'objet de débat entre les sociétés
concessionnaires la DGITM et la DGC qui
doivent aboutir à la réalisation et à la
publication d'un schéma directeur de des
bornes de recharge électrique permettant
d'assurer
l'alimentation de l'ensemble du parc à
échéance de sa croissance sur la
question du photovoltaïque sur laquelle
j'ai eu un propos liminaire et vous me
relancer
nous avons fait un travail entre VINCI
Autoroutes et la SNCF
permettant d'évaluer grossièrement faut
pas grossièrement on a
évalué à 5000 hectares le foncier
disponible le long des voies de chemin
de fer il y a 4000 hectares d'après la
SNCF le long des voies de chemin de fer
et moi j'ai identifié 1000 hectares sur
le réseau Vinci autoroute et vous savez
qu'en gros sur un hectare on peut faire
un méga ce qui veut dire que sur ces
5000 hectares on pourrait faire 5 Go ce
qui veut dire qu'en mobilisant
rapidement le foncier existant le long
des infrastructures on pourrait grosso
modo faire l'équivalent de 5 centrales
nucléaires en photovoltaïque ça
représente de l'ordre de 5 milliards
d'euros d'investissement et nous y
sommes prêts je veux pas parler au nom
de la SNCF mais je peux dire que nous
avons travaillé avec l'équipe de la SNCF
sur ce sujet et que nous avons fait des
propositions
il me semble qu'on gagnerait à
simplifier l'ensemble des procédures
pour créer un régime Maddox sur les
infrastructures linéaires pour poser des
panneaux photovoltaïques le long des le
long des autoroutes ou des voies de
chemin de fer ce qui me paraîtrait pas
très pas très compliqué et ce qui serait
très efficace en termes de production
nous y sommes prêts nous sommes prêts à
la fois administrativement techniquement
et financièrement à faire cette cet
effort encore faut-il que le cadre légal
le permet ce qui est pas le cas
aujourd'hui mais nous espérons que un
prochain
véhicule législatif permettra de le
permettra de relancer le sujet pardon
alors nous avons lu dans le détail le
projet de loi énergie renouvelable et si
vous voulez on part d'un schéma ou avec
l'ensemble des procédures applicables il
faut de l'ordre de 5 ans pour déployer
un panneau et il nous semble que on doit
pouvoir comprimer ces délais et je n'ai
pas vu dans la loi la possibilité de les
réduire de plus de quelques mois à date
mais je suis bien sûr ouvert au
débat sur ce
sur ce sujet
je voudrais maintenant
revenir puisque vous vous m'y invitez
sur la question de de la rentabilité
j'ai répondu sur la transparence je
redis que la question de la RT et fin le
travail fait par la RT me semble purger
le sujet et que ça n'est pas en
multipliant les modèles et les
hypothèses qu'on réglera le sujet donc
je suis issu navré d'insister mais je
pense qu'il est important de lire le
travail qui a été fait par par la RT sur
le sur le sujet sur
l'interpellation de
de Jacques Pernic concernant le l'enjeu
d'intérêt général je veux dire que les
concessionnaires
d'autoroute réalisent des missions de
service public dans le cadre de la loi
et dans le cadre des contrats et que
nous sommes évidemment Mobilis sur la
mobilisation des moyens d'investissement
privé
au service des projets qui ont été
évoqués que ce soit ceux que j'ai évoqué
dans mon propos liminaires ou ce que
vous avez les uns et les autres évoqués
les concessionnaires ne font
qu'appliquer les obligations ou les
commandes qui sont faites par l'État et
c'est vrai aujourd'hui s'agissant du
photovoltaïque ou s'agissant des bornes
de recharge électrique et ça peut être
vrai demain sur la résilience merci
d'avoir pointé ce sujet nous sommes de
plus en plus soumis et nos
infrastructures sont de plus en plus
soumises à des chocs climatiques qui
s'agissent d'inondations ou qu'il
s'agisse de d'incendie et c'est
important de le prendre en compte et
probablement de concevoir un plan de
résilience permettant d'adapter les
infrastructures c'est vrai dans le Sud
où notamment chez Escota nous sommes
beaucoup soumis à des les incendies mais
c'est vrai aussi s'agissant je pense à
l'autoroute A9 qui a subi récemment un
épisode de pluie qui a été qualifié de
Millenial et qui a tout emporté et
manifestement il y a des travaux
d'adaptation et des travaux
d'anticipation des changements
climatiques pour adapter les pour
adapter les infrastructures alors j'en
viens à l'interpellation sur la question
qui a été posée
j'accepte de revenir sur le sujet de de
la rentabilité et donc de la rentabilité
du taux de rentabilité actionnaire
puisque vous vous invitez monsieur le
sénateur je voudrais sur sur ce sujet
dire d'abord qu'il y a pas eu d'erreur
je voudrais j'ai été interpellé tout à
l'heure par un journaliste devant la
porte de cette salle et je lui rappelais
que lorsque les concessions d'autoroute
ont été privatisées en 2005 le journal
des échos se féliciter de la bonne
affaire réalisée par l'État dans la
session des sociétés concessionnaires
d'autoroute et
mentionner que l'État se déchargeait à
la fois de risques travaux de risque de
financement de risque trafic et d'une
dette qui était très significative parce
qu'on parle régulièrement lorsqu'on
parle de la session des autoroutes des
fameux 14 milliards mais faut pas
oublier qu'il y avait attaché aux
sociétés concessionnaires une dette qui
était de l'ordre de 20 milliards et qui
avait des investissements différés
c'est-à-dire des obligations d'investir
dans les contrats j'ai recalué que
depuis 2005 l'ensemble des sociétés
concessionnaires ont investi 30
milliards d'euros sur les réseaux avec
des extensions avec des élargissements
ou des ouvrages d'adaptation donc les
concessions d'autoroute c'est plus que
le montant des sessions initiales c'est
le montant du capital plus la dette plus
les investissements différés et je
répète que vu de 2005 l'État a fait une
une bonne affaire est-ce que il y a eu
erreur sur la valorisation qu'on
retrouverait aujourd'hui dans la
rentabilité des actionnaires
personnellement je ne le crois pas parce
que j'ai suivi ce sujet à toutes les
étapes et qui en 2005 pouvait imaginer
que les comment aller évoluer les taux
d'intérêt personne et d'ailleurs
personne ne sait aujourd'hui comment
vont évoluer les taux d'intérêt dans les
années qui viennent à la suite de 2005
nous avons subi la crise de Lehman
Brother c'est je me souviens qu'à SF en
2005 a fait une émission obligataire
entre 7 et 8% j'ai pu le taux précis
mais on était au-dessus de 7% et le
trafic des poids lourds avait baissé de
20% et on se attendez si on arriverait à
mettre les cash flows nécessaires en
face de de l'endettement ensuite nous
avons subi une période où nous avons
bénéficié d'une période de baisse des
taux d'intérêt qui est très
significative et qui est manifestement
ce qui alimente la chronique sur le
sujet et qui fait débat sauf qu'il se
trouve que aujourd'hui les taux
d'intérêt remonte donc oui nous sommes
partis avec un taux d'intérêt moyen qui
était de 4% et nous sommes descendus à
un taux d'intérêt qui était autour de un
taux d'intérêt moyen qui est autour de
1% et la dernière fois que nous nous
sommes endettés c'était il y a quelques
semaines nous avons fait une émission
obligatoire qui était à 3,25 et moi je
ne sais pas celui qu'il sait sera riche
mais moi je ne sais pas quels seront les
taux d'intérêt dans un mois dans un an
ou ou dans 5 ans mais par contre je sais
que je porte ce risque et que je porte
comme concessionnaire la dette et le
risque qui va avec
le débat qui est derrière le la
chronique alimentée par un journal
satirique qui s'amuse beaucoup mais qui
rentre pas dans le détail de de ce
modèle c'est celui de la rentabilité des
actionnaires et c'est celui de savoir si
le montant investit est-elle bon moi je
crois simplement qu'on peut rappeler que
dans le modèle de la privatisation dans
le cahier des charges de la
privatisation on ne parlait ni de terre
et projet ni de terre et actionnaires on
parlait de la privatisation d'une
société qui était déjà côté en bourse et
qui avait été évalué lors de son
introduction en bourse avec les
différentes méthodes possibles depuis on
a privatisé des tas d'autres sociétés
y compris d'ailleurs des entreprises de
service public et personne ne va
calculer quel est le tri actionnaire de
France Télécom privatisé à la même
époque où de la Française des jeux
privatisés l'année dernière donc on peut
faire des polémiques longtemps on peut
recalculer le modèle d'ASF en se
demandant quel a été la rentabilité pour
ASF du fait de
s'endetter en relongeant la dette
d'acquisition quand la maison mère a
relogé la dette d'acquisition sur la
société mais c'était écrit au contrat
donc là non plus c'était écrit au cahier
des charges de la de la privatisation
donc là non plus il n'y a ni surprise ni
mystère ni question de de transparence
ce que je voudrais simplement dire c'est
que sur cet instrument de mesure le tri
actionnaire comme sur le tri projet ce
sont des qui peut faire l'objet
d'évaluation à date mais ce sont des
sujets qui ne pourront être mesurés qu'à
la fin des concessions le Conseil d'État
a le ministre des Finances l'a annoncé
le Conseil d'État a été saisi doit être
saisie de cette question je voudrais
simplement rappeler que le Conseil
d'État
toutes les concessions
font l'objet de décret en Conseil d'État
tous les textes fondateurs des
concessions et tous les avenants ont
fait l'objet de décret en Conseil d'État
depuis 1955
tous les avenants ont été examinés par
le Conseil d'État tous ont été jugés à
l'aune du théorie projet les concessions
sont jugées et mesurées à l'aune du tri
projet et le Conseil d'État a toujours
fonctionné comme ça voilà après encore
une fois on peut
débattre et
on peut alimenter la chronique avec des
chiffres qui par définition sont très
élevées compte tenues de la nature même
du modèle des sociétés concessionnaires
qui financent des
investissements je rappelle que dans le
dans la comptabilité de l'État les
sociétés concessionnaires les
concessions d'autoroute sont évaluées à
200 milliards d'euros donc ce sont des
montants gigantesques les sociétés
concessionnaires les ont construits
elles portent encore une partie de la
dette et une partie des programmes
d'investissement pour les entretiens et
pour la modernisation du réseau c'est le
schéma que nous avons construit
quand on l'évalue avec les indicateurs
de suivi contractuels personne ne
conteste la qualité du travail qui a été
fait lorsqu'on regarde la satisfaction
des clients et quand on regarde les
indices de satisfaction tels qui sont
mesurées année après année par un
institut de sondage qui est qui est
piloté par l'État on a un niveau
satisfaction qui est entre 8 et 9 sur 10
bon je ne peux que me contenter de le
constater et donc je voudrais également
dire
et je le dis au nom des 6000 salariés de
Vinci Autoroutes que
nous avons des équipes qui sont
mobilisées et qui font bien leur travail
nous avons des équipes qui travaillent
24 heures sur 24 7 jours sur 7 et qui
veille sur la sécurité des usagers et je
voudrais dire qu'à force le dénigrement
ou les polémiques qui entourent ce sujet
finissent par être pesant donc je
autorise en plus je crois que cette
audition est filmée donc je m'autorise à
dire que je rends hommage au travail qui
est fait par nos salariés et je dois je
m'autoriser également à revendiquer la
fierté du travail qui a été réalisé dans
l'exécution du contrat dans la
construction des ouvrages et dans
l'entretien maintenant j'ajoute que nous
avons multiplié les innovations en
matière de service et en matière
d'installation commerciale les
installations commerciales des sociétés
d'autoroute telles qu'elles ont été
modernisées offrent en matière de
restauration de boutique et de
carburants des niveaux de prestation qui
sont incomparablement meilleurs que
celles qui avaient avant et incomparable
en meilleure que ce que
on constate sur le reste du réseau
routier national voilà ce que je voulais
dire sur ce sujet mais
en fait sur la question des tarifs merci
de me le rappeler
le décret de 95 prévoit une indexation
des tarifs
70% de l'inflation et c'est là-dessus
qui a été calculé le modèle de
valorisation des concessions et ça c'est
pas fait par hasard c'est à dire que on
me dit aujourd'hui à mais oui mais tu as
des charges qui sont moins importantes
que l'indexation c'est vrai des charges
d'exploitation mais c'est pas vrai des
charges financières puisque les taux
d'intérêt remontent et c'est encore
moins vrai des charges de travaux
puisque les travaux que nous réalisons
année après année sont très impactés par
l'inflation donc si vous voulez le
modèle prévoit un ensemble de
d'obligations et un ensemble
d'ingrédients les charges d'exploitation
les charges d'investissement les charges
financières et l'indexation de la loi
tarifaire elle est la contrepartie de du
risque que nous prenons en assumant
l'ensemble de ces charges donc
ça n'est en rien un peu limite de dire
que les tarifs continueront d'augmenter
je dis simplement que les tarifs sont
indexés à l'inflation et je souhaite
comme vous que l'inflation baisse
bien merci
l'audition devait durer une heure et
quart ça dans une minute c'est on a
respecté le temps
d'audition merci monsieur le Président
pour vous répondre merci à vous monsieur
le Président merci et puis on va passer
à l'audition suivante merci merci
beaucoup
mes chers collègues pour ne pas terminer
trop tard
je vous propose de regagner vos places
et
afin que nous poursuivions ce cycle
d'audition
Monsieur le Directeur Général mes chers
collègues
nous en venons à la dernière audition de
cette matinée consacrée à l'avenir des
concessions autoroutières
nous accueillons Monsieur Arnaud Kemar
directeur général du groupe sanaf qui
exploite environ 1800 km de l'autoroute
à titre luminaire je me permets
seulement de rappeler que notre
commission souhaite à travers ce cycle
d'audition que nous avons débuté
aujourd'hui anticiper la fin des
contrats de concession autoroutier et à
faire en quelque sorte le bilan des
concessions telles qu'elles ont été
pensées et mises en oeuvre jusqu'à
présent dans cette perspective je
souhaiterais vous interroger sur les
quatre mêmes points que ceux évoqués
avec Monsieur Pierre Copé
ma première question est de nature
plutôt prospective comment
appréhendez-vous la fin des contrats de
concession et comment l'anticiper vous
je souhaiterais en particulier savoir
dans quelle mesure et comment vous
préparez à la restitution des biens ou
en sont les inventaires des biens de
retour et la définition d'une doctrine
quant au bon état cible de ses biens
seconde question porte cela ne vous
étonnera pas
sans doute sur la rentabilité des
concessions sujettes à de nombreux
commentaires plusieurs rapports récents
notamment celui de l'Inspection Générale
des Finances qui a récemment fuité dans
la presse dans la montrer que certaines
SCA ont des taux de rentabilité bien
supérieurs ce qui était prévu par les
contrats de concession certains
suggèrent d'étudier l'opportunité de
raccourcir la durée de certains contrats
Bruno Le Maire a indiqué avoir saisi le
Conseil d'État sur cette question que
répondez-vous à de tels discours et
propositions j'en viens à ma troisième
question qui porte quant à elle sur la
fiscalité des autoroutes la première
ministre a évoqué l'idée de faire
davantage contribuer le secteur
autoroutier au plan d'avenir pour les
transports et notamment en faveur du
monde ferroviaire quel regard
portez-vous sur cette proportion je
rappelle que les sociétés
concessionnaires d'autoroute remettent
en cause depuis 2021 le versement de la
contribution volontaires exceptionnel à
l'Agence de financement des
infrastructures de transport à Lafitte
compte tenu de l'indexation de la taxe
d'aménagement du territoire sur
l'inflation faut-il s'attendre à une
réaction similaire si d'éventuelle
nouvelle taxe était prévue des
discussions avec le gouvernement
ont-elles déjà été engagés sur ce point
enfin pouvez-vous évoquer quels moyens
sont consacrés à la décarbonation des
autoroutes avez-vous estimé les besoins
totaux en la matière avant de vous céder
la parole pour une durée de 10 minutes
au maximum je précise que nous en fait
le choix d'entendre un grand nombre de
d'acteurs ce qui a pour conséquence de
limiter à 1h15 chacune des auditions de
notre matinée je voudrais donc de
respecter le temps de parole car de la
même manière en pleine accord avec les
chefs de fil de chaque groupe nous avons
convenu qu'un seul orateur par groupe
politique interviendrait et disposerait
de 4 minutes pour le groupe les
républicains le groupe socialiste
écologique et républicain et de 3
minutes pour les autres groupes hormis
le compignon centr iste puisque j'ai
fait l'intervention luminaire Monsieur
le Directeur général je vous cède la
parole
monsieur le Président merci beaucoup
mesdames messieurs les sénateurs je suis
ravi devant vous pour cette pour cet
audition dans ce dans un contexte qui
est toujours enfin je veux dire un
contexte particulier mais dans les
autoroutes on est toujours dans un
contexte particulier donc c'est c'est
l'intérêt de c'est un des grands
intérêts de ce métier
d'abord dans pour commencer je voudrais
rappeler deux mots d'histoire de mode
histoire très rapidement en fait les
concessions autoroutières c'est c'est un
objet qui existe depuis les années 50 le
groupe SANEF a été fondé en 1963 donc ça
va faire 60 ans cette année que le
groupe SANEF existe qu'est-ce que ça a
permis ce modèle de concessions
autoroutière je pense que c'est très
important de le rappeler ça a permis de
réaliser de très grands investissements
c'est durant ces 60 ans c'est 10000 km
d'autoroute qui ont été construits
d'abord des autoroutes de liaison et
ensuite des autoroutes de desserts de
territoire qui ont été adossés aux
autoroutes existantes c'est un réseau
d'une qualité
Argentine d'Italie d'Espagne pour pour
apprécier la qualité à la fois de
l'entretien et de l'infrastructure
autoroutière qui est qui est à la
disposition de tous les Français
si on revient un petit peu sur
l'histoire on est donc à 60 ans de
concessions c'est 60 ans de concessions
puisque ça sera forcément un moment une
question qu'on va partager ici c'est
est-ce que c'est une durée qui est trop
longue qui est trop courte en fait la
durée la durée est directement liée à la
masse d'investissement et on a
effectivement pendant ces 60 ans
construit 10000 km d'autoroute qui
dessert qui dessert l'intégralité du
territoire la concession c'est aussi un
transfert de risques et là je refais un
tout petit peu d'histoire puisque en
fait dans un moment on a l'impression
que le métier de concessionnaire est un
métier de rentier un stère m'a été
utilisé très très très couramment il
faut se rappeler à s'attendre d'épisodes
dans notre histoire il faut se rappeler
les chocs pétroliers de 73 et 79 et à
cette époque cinq concessionnaires
routier sur 6 on fait faillite c'est ce
qui s'est passé à cette époque avec la
conjonction d'une baisse de trafic liée
à des augmentations du coût de l'essence
considérable mais aussi un
renchérissement important des coûts des
travaux dans une phase de de
construction importante c'est pas très
éloigné de ce qu'on a pu connaître très
très récemment je le mentionne nos
l'inflation l'an dernier a fait
augmenter nos coûts travaux de chaussée
de 20% en une année donc il y a il y a
il y a ces effets et ce n'est pas un
métier sans risque pas un métier sans
risque puisqu'on a subi la crise de 2008
et je l'ai déjà dit mais je le redis les
trafics poids lourds ne le niveau de
trafic poid lourd de 2008 n'a été de
2007 n'a été retrouvé qu'en 2019
on a subi évidemment les crises récentes
des gilets jaunes et du covid dans une
société du groupe SANEF donc la société
des autoroutes Paris Normandie
à failli faire faillite donc c'était
avant la maladie de privatisation a
failli faire vaillent et a été adossé au
groupe SANEF tout simplement parce que
elle était en incapacité en incapacité
financière de subvenir aux besoins de la
construction de l'autoroute A14 donc
notamment du grand tunnel sous la forêt
de Saint-Germain dont les coups avaient
dans les coups avaient explosé donc ça
n'est pas un métier qui est totalement
totalement sans risque
et on en subit et on en a subi l'an
dernier et on a subi très très
régulièrement si je reviens sur une
étape importante qui est l'étape de la
privatisation l'étape ladite étape de la
privatisation on se rappelle bien les
autoroutes n'ont pas été privatisées
c'est ce sont les les actions des
sociétés d'autoroute qui ont été qui ont
été vendus par le biais d'un d'un appel
d'offres et et donc le contrat tel qu'il
était avant et après donc avec l'État
actionnaire ou le le les sociétés
privées actionnaires à peu ouprou peu
modifier depuis 2000 depuis 2015 l'État
a considérablement et ça va venir à une
de vos questions monsieur le Président a
considérablement
resserré le cadre à la fois législatif
et contractuel des concessions
autoroutières j'en citerai quelques
exemples le premier exemple c'est la loi
Macron 2015 qui a mis en place la RT
dont aujourd'hui tout le monde loue les
bénéfices en termes de de transparence
et de qualité des rapports qui sont
produits par cette autorité indépendante
laquelle art dans le cadre des avenants
plus récents au contrat de concession
contraint le fameux théorie donc avec un
Terry qui donne qui qui donne qui qui
fait l'objet pardon d'un avis de la RT
et puis le constédant à lui-même
considérablement renforcé les contrôles
nous avions déjà depuis longtemps des
indicateurs de bon état d'entretien de
notre de notre patrimoine donc une
vingtaine d'indicateurs tous les ans
depuis nombreuses années nous sommes
conformes voire très très au-dessus des
niveaux attendus sur chacun des
indicateurs à la fois de sécurité mais
aussi d'entretien de notre patrimoine
est très récemment dans un avenant qui a
été signé en juin en janvier pardon de
cette année nous avons été la première
société d'autoroute a intégré une annexe
qui s'appelle une annexe de bon état
d'entretien en fin de concession bon
état d'entretien en fin de concession
vous le savez les contrats originaux
contiennent une phrase très générale qui
dit que les autoroutes doivent être
rendues en bon état et bien c'est suite
a aussi un travail important avec notre
conséquent que nous avons
je dirais concrétiser factualiser et mis
dans des indicateurs des indicateurs
indiscutables la notion de bon état
d'entretien afin de concession dans la
ligne droite ligne d'ailleurs des
indicateurs que aujourd'hui qui sont
vérifiés aujourd'hui par notre par
l'État et sur lequel nous sommes
focaliser si nous n'atteignons pas ces
niveaux donc comment nous nous préparons
première réponse à votre question
comment nous nous préparons nous nous
préparons déjà depuis longtemps avec des
discussions techniques puisque ceci est
un travail d'ingénieur donc ce sont des
ingénieurs du côté des sociétés
d'autoroute et des ingénieurs du côté
des services de l'État qui discutent de
quel est le bon état et aujourd'hui ce
que je peux vous dire c'est que le
réseau SANEF et les indicateurs en
atteste est en excellente état et propre
à être propre à être remis aux
conséquent dans la procédure qui est
prévue contractuellement c'est à dire
sept ans avant la fin de la concession
il y a un audit qui est réalisé on a
déjà commencé à aller Surger des données
on a commencé déjà à travailler sur la
qualification du du patrimoine des
différents éléments de patrimoine
essayez une un processus qui est en
marche et dans un dialogue constant et
permanent avec les avec les services de
l'État ça va être effectivement un très
gros travail de part et d'autre mais le
fait d'avoir commencé à contractualiser
des éléments techniques et non pas des
éléments qui qui sont qui sont du
domaine du subjectif puisque le bon état
quiconque a déjà fait un inventaire ou
un état des lieux d'un appartement
location c'est très bien qu'entre le
propriétaire et le locataire il y a en
général une différence assez profonde de
d'appréciation du niveau du bon état
voilà voilà
est-ce que c'est pas pensé pour cette
petite pour cette petite comparaison et
donc nous avons là pour ne pas nous
retrouver dans cette situation un peu
US qu'on pourrait pendant des années
avoir un contentieux sur quel est le bon
état nous avons commencé à faire un
travail détaillé je rappelle un vrai
travail d'ingénieur d'ingénieur TP pour
savoir quel est le quel est le bon état
le bon état il est effectivement
excellent surtout quand on se compare au
réseau national et c'est important quand
on quand on se pose la question du futur
des concessions ça a déjà été dit je le
redis 15% du réseau national non
concédés considéré comme en bon état
aujourd'hui 85% du réseau concédé
considéré comme en bon état et sa
personne n'en doute
et je pense que tous les sondages
montrent que sans pour faire une très
très grande proportion des Français sont
extrêmement satisfaits de la qualité de
leurs réseaux de leurs réseaux
autoroutiers
en excellent état en particulier en ce
qui concerne les ouvrages d'art on se
rappelle des épisodes qui ont été
extrêmement douloureux à l'étranger sur
sur les ouvrages d'art je rappelle un
petit rapport qui a été un petit un
grand rapport qui a été produit il y a
quelques années sur les ouvrages d'art
du réseau non concédé il y a aujourd'hui
sur le réseau non concédés un tiers des
ouvrages d'art qui nécessitent une
réparation
urgente il y a 7% je cite le même
rapport de l'imdm il y a 7 % des
ouvrages d'art qui sont dans un risque
d'effondrement
et le temps entre la détection d'un d'un
réparation nécessaire et la la d'un
défaut nécessaire de réparation et le
temps de réparation et selon ce rapport
de 22 ans voilà évidemment j'ai pas
besoin de vous dire que sur le réseau
concédé ce genre de choses ne se passe
pas tout simplement parce qu'il y a un
indicateur de performance sur
l'entretien des réseaux qui ne nous
permet pas d'attendre 22 ans évidemment
pour réparer un ouvrage d'art alors vous
allez me dire donc votre question c'est
quelle est la fin et quel est l'avenir
finalement des concessions c'est
fondamentalement moi je suis
concessionnaire donc je je ne suis pas
l'état et c'est fondament
fondamentalement un choix stratégique
pour l'État insta un choix stratégique
pour l'État tout simplement parce que en
premier lieu le choix du péage
le choix de continuer à collecter le
péage j'ai déjà expliqué pourquoi je
pense que le pH est quelque chose qui
est juste juste parce que c'est
l'utilisateur payeur juste parce que ça
permet de faire contribuer les étrangers
juste mais mais nécessite peut-être à
l'avenir d'être réadapté réadapté dans
les zones périurbaines est-ce que le pH
de 2030 est plus doit être exactement
sous la même forme et aux Enzo et je
pense que ça c'est vous et lui des
territoires c'est quelque chose qui vous
qui vous concerne particulièrement
est-ce que tous les territoires doivent
être traités de manière équitable et
puis et comment est-ce que le pH peut
financer d'autres modes de transport
c'est une de c'est une de vos questions
c'est aujourd'hui un cas c'est
aujourd'hui déjà le cas les sociétés
d'autoroute contribuent largement aux
autres modes de transport par les taxes
et par la contribution volontaire
exceptionnelle mais attention à l'euro
vignette et aux contraintes qui sont
données par par la directive
Eurovignette parce que tout ce qui est
aujourd'hui possible en matière de pH ne
sera pas forcément possible demain le
choix du modèle contractuel ça aussi
c'est forcément un choix stratégique de
l'État je pense et je l'ai dit dans mon
propos d'introduction sur le passé le
modèle de la concession a montré tous
ces tous ces avantages je pense que ce
modèle doit absolument perdurer
peut-être avec un meilleur encadrement
de la responsabilité peut-être avec un
contrôle renforcé mais tout en gardant
et c'est important pour nous qui sommes
acteurs européens tout en gardant dans
le cas de d'appel à la concurrence de
nouvelles concessions un caractère
attractif pour des investisseurs qui ne
sont pas forcément que des investisseurs
français je pense que
ce sont des des concessions qui doivent
être attractives pour des acteurs un peu
différents des acteurs traditionnels du
marché du marché français
d'un détail homogène aujourd'hui il y a
des concessions qui sont dans des
détails extrêmement différents des très
très grande et beaucoup plus des
beaucoup plus petites je pense qu'il
doit y avoir un moment à un autre à
redécoupage géographique des réseaux
français de manière à avoir une
meilleure homogénéité de l'ensemble des
réseaux tout en ayant des tailles
critiques suffisantes de manière à ce
que ce sauter soit autonome et pas
nécessairement adossé à des grands
groupes voilà et sur les durées les
durées évidemment des durées courtes
plus courtes et qui dépendent
fondamentalement comme je l'ai dit tout
à l'heure des montants à investir et
d'ici là qu'est-ce qu'on doit faire
puisque finalement les concessions c'est
2030 et je vais venir à votre autre
question sur les fins des concessions
c'est 2031 ce qui concerne sa neige
jusqu'en 2036 vous connaissez par cœur
ces dates on a d'ores et déjà des enjeux
on le sait on a des enjeux
environnementaux qui ne pourront pas
atteindre la fin de la fin des
concessions
leur l'enjeu majeur est en la
décarbonation des transports si on fixe
quelques ordres de grandeur les
émissions de CO2 des des clients
circulants sur le réseau SANEF c'est 1,8
% des émissions de CO2 de la France
pour moitié les véhicules légers pour
l'autre moitié les poids lourds en ce
qui concerne les véhicules légers nous
avons au moment où on parle on a
installé sur 100% de nos airs de nos
aires de de service donc sur les 72
heures de service des bandes de recharge
à très haute puissance de qui vont de
150 kW à 350 kW qui qui vont permettre
de faciliter voilà la décarbonation des
des véhicules légers le point qui reste
en suspens c'est évidemment la
décarbonation des poids lourds sur
lequel on sait très bien il n'y a aucune
solution mature au moment où on parle
mais quand on voit l'évolution qui s'est
passé ces 10 dernières années dans
l'immobilité qui aurait pu parier
d'ailleurs que on est une explosion du
véhicule électrique qui a il y a cela 10
ans
ça va nécessiter forcément des
investissements les investissements qui
seront en fin de concession donc des
investissements qui ne pourront pas être
amortis dans le cadre dans le cadre
normal de la de la de la concession de
notre côté vous l'avez peut-être vu on
a fait un partenariat avec avec seva qui
est l'ancien Geodis et engie et avec
engie pour expérimenter des solutions de
de logistique permettant d'exploiter sur
les réseaux autoroutiers des camions
électriques avec un principe que je
reviendrai tout à l'heure si vous avez
une question dessus qui est le principe
en fait des relais de poste en fait donc
de tous les 400 km mettre des bornes de
recharge eau de puissante et de changer
finalement les tracteurs de proche en
proche et de faire avancer la la
marchandise disons de d'un point à un
autre de manière totalement décarbonée
je ne peux pas vous dire combien
d'investissements et je serai je suis
incapable de vous dire combien
d'investissements seront nécessaires
d'ici la fin de concession pour la
décarbonation nous y sommes déjà très
engagés nous avons nous sommes en train
de construire des pôles de Georges
multimodo des voies réservées nous
sommes en point sur les sur le
covoiturage sur la protection de la
diversité mais ça va encore nécessiter
des investissements enfin et pour
conclure ce premier ce propos je pense
que on a un enjeu collectif un enjeu
collectif qui est excusez-moi
l'expression mais de ne pas jeter le
bébé avec l'eau du bain et de continuer
à profiter de cet outil extraordinaire
extrêmement efficace qui sont les
concessions autoroutières qui sont un
facteur de compétitivité du pays quand
on à l'heure on parle de
réindustrialisation du pays c'est un la
la la la la qualité et la disponibilité
du réseau autoroutier est fondamentale
pour l'industrie des gestion du pays et
puis c'est un vecteur et ça reste pour
très longtemps et de très très
nombreuses années le vecteur de
transport de millions de Français au
quotidien et donc il faut
repenser le modèle il faut ajuster
peut-être certainement les contrats les
contrats de concession mais certainement
pas
jeter le bébé avec l'eau du bain et est
passé et passé à un autre modèle dont je
crains qu'il soit moins vertueux que
celui-ci
merci donc je vais donner la parole à
mes collègues il y a un collègue par
groupe qui intervient et vous répondra à
la fin
alors je vais donner la parole au groupe
RDPI et à Nadège avait merci monsieur le
Président ma question ou plutôt mes
interrogations sont les suivantes en
janvier l'Autorité de régulation des
transports à préconisés dans un rapport
consacré à l'économie des concessions
routières là
le raccourcissement pardon des contrats
afin de permettre des remises en
concurrence plus régulière
sur la base de quel constat celui d'un
déséquilibre au profit des acteurs que
permet le système actuel c'est ce qu'a
fait souligner le ministre Bruno Le
Maire il y a une semaine devant les
députés estimant que le calcul fait à
l'époque de la privatisation des
autoroutes il y a 15 ans n'avait pas été
bon et il a eu pour ainsi il y a eu pour
ainsi dire sur rentabilité c'est
pourquoi le Conseil d'État a été
sollicité dans son rapport de début
d'année la RT ne remet pas en question
le système en tant que tel mais pointes
des faiblesses notamment des
négociations déséquilibrées auprès de au
profit concessionnaires des contrats
plus courts sont préconisés dans
certains cas par le régulateur avançant
dans le même temps des nouvelles
modalités de financement innovantes ces
contrats pourraient être plus courts par
exemple dans le cas d'une concession
nécessitant pas ou peu de travaux ou
plus longs dans le cas contraire
j'aurais souhaité avoir votre
positionnement sur ce point également
sur celui de l'adaptation au changement
climatiques des besoins d'investissement
vont être à prévoir sur le réseau à ce
niveau on connaissez-vous le volume et
on connaissez-vous la nature je vous
remercie
merci
la parole est pour le groupe RCE Gérard
merci monsieur le Président Monsieur le
Président
merci pour votre
participation à cette
initiative qui concourt beaucoup à plus
de transparence sur un sujet
important permettez-moi de vous dire
aussi que je n'ai pas la moindre réserve
quant aux partenariats que l'on peut
construire entre institution institution
d'État collectivités et des groupes
comme le vôtre à titre indicatif après
le bien du MI de Millau
nous avons eu la LGV pour la Bretagne
preuve s'il en était besoin que le
groupe peut aussi avoir le souci du
développement des modes alternatifs à la
haute et ça dans le cadre d'un contrat
de partenariat donc vous voyez pas de
réserve quant au modèle concertif
pas de doute non plus sur la capacité à
construire ensemble dans une forme de
mixité bien entendu
mixité publique privée
évidemment ce qui réhausse la
responsabilité du public en ce sens que
nous devons aussi être bon en
mathématiques en droit
pour être capable de le relever je
dirais collectivement les défis qui sont
qui sont de devant nous donc pas de
doute mais nous sommes dans un contexte
tout de même assez agité
ou la presse se fait régulièrement
l'écho de beaucoup de choses
il arrive que le livre de chevet soit
plus la presse que le rapport de la RT
malheureusement bien que il soit utile
et qu'il soit un indicateur de
connaissance qu'il ne faut pas négliger
il est important de tenir compte quand
même du contexte dans lequel nous sommes
et du reste ceci n'a pas été totalement
étranger au fait que
le ministre le maire et se sentit obligé
de faire quelques commentaires sur
lesquels je ne reviendrai pas
alors un groupe comme le vôtre avec son
expertise ne peut pas être insensible à
ce contexte
et même s'il est vrai que l'échéance de
2031 n'est pas si éloigné que ça de nous
sûrement avez-vous quelle idée
sur les dispositions qui pourraient être
envisagées
pour surmonter la difficulté objective à
laquelle on est confronté notamment sur
la question
évidemment des marges réalisées des
marges contractuelles et donc dans le
respect évidemment des limites du droit
des affaires il n'y a pas besoin de
demande pas que tout soit révélé ici en
plus paraît-il nous sommes filmés mais
peut-être
avez-vous quelqu'un tension sur les
adaptations possibles qui n'insulte pas
l'avenir et qui rétablirait un peu de
sérénité au regard des débats dont je
parlais tout à l'heure merci
la parole pour le groupe Les
Indépendants est à Pierre miedevielle
merci monsieur le Président Monsieur le
Directeur Général merci pour votre
exposé très clair bon nous sommes
beaucoup parlé ce matin moi
personnellement j'étais vice-président
de groupe d'études qui avait été mis en
place en 2015 sur l'étude des
concessions les possibilités de reprise
nous étions ce qui rend peu la
Commission le rapport à la commission
d'enquête un peu redondant je le dis ce
matin puisque nous étions tombés à peu
près sur les mêmes conclusions et à
l'époque c'est vrai que les rapports de
la l'Autorité de la concurrence et du
cabinet mandaté par Ségolène Royal avait
été largement décrié même par un grand
nombre de membres du gouvernement puis
c'était des rapports à charge tu te
calcules juridique une rentabilité à
l'instant T qui ne voulait pas dire
grand chose bon c'est un nouveau rapport
chaque rapport il se veut souvent chaud
amène son lot de polémique d'indignation
qui font traverser des zones de
turbulences surtout en période
d'inflation
comme nous nous sommes aujourd'hui ou
stigmatise un peu toutes les entreprises
qui font trop de bénéfices faire entre
guillemets comme les fournisseurs
d'énergie de société d'autoroute mais
moi je les redis je le redis je préfère
avoir des sociétés qui font du bénéfice
ce qui est quand même synonyme de
d'investissement et d'emploi et nous en
avons grandement besoin donc pensez-vous
que
le modèle actuel vous l'avez dit je
pensais vous qui peut être reconduit
cela devra se faire je pense dans un
climat qui sera apaisé beaucoup plus
serein que ce qu'il est aujourd'hui
puisque le négociation se font dans la
vie dans le calme on ne sait pas en
livrant les concessionnaires en pâture à
la presse en leur mettant la pression
comme cet Élie ce matin je pense qu'on
peut amener une discussion et une
négociation qui doit aboutir c'est c'est
quand même le but bon je pense que nous
avons besoin aussi et vous me répondent
d'un partenariat entre l'État et les
concessionnaires pour aborder ce virage
de la transition énergétique
qui est au combien important si on veut
réduire nos émissions de carbone
notamment en matière de poids lourds il
y a plusieurs solutions plusieurs pistes
envisagées votre collègue coupé en a
ouvert une ce matin avec le mais je
crois que les solutions seront sont
inventées en matière de véhicule
électrique ou de véhicules à hydrogène
et puisque nous nous sommes là dernière
question j'ai parlé des rapports chocs
que pensez-vous du rapport de la
commission d'enquête de
et de ses conclusions
merci chers collègues je vais donner la
parole pour le groupe Gesta Jacques
oui merci monsieur le Président Monsieur
le Président donc merci d'apporter des
réponses précises à nos questions sur le
futur de notre réseau autoroutier et les
impératifs à prendre en compte donc
évidemment
l'impératif d'avoir un réseau performant
de bonne qualité et la nouveauté
considérable un réseau qui soit
résilient aux impacts très forts du
réchauffement climatique
l'impératif pour les contrats en cours
comme pour ceux qui leur succédera à des
conditions de coopération entre le
public et le privé qui soit moins
déséquilibré entre les actionnaires
l'État et les usagers qui cadrent mieux
les écarts par rapport à l'équilibre
économique et financier et qui assure un
suivi partagé transparent et des clauses
de revoyure pour
rectifier ce qui s'imposerait vous avez
dit je crois deux trois fois qu'il
fallait pas jeter le bébé avec l'eau du
bain notre souci c'est aussi que le bébé
soit soit net bien lavé
relaver régulièrement et que l'eau ne
soit pas un coup exorbitant au profit de
quelques-uns j'arrêterai là la métaphore
filée oui et troisième impératif
évidemment c'est celui de la
décarbonation avec la transition
d'électromobilité accélérée avec aussi
l'évolution amener de l'usage de la
route il s'agit pas de reproduire le
même parc de véhicules simplement avec
une motorisation différente mais réduire
l'auto-solisme et rendre plus efficient
le transport routier de marchandises
pour cette décarbonation on parle de
rééquilibrer la la compétition
routraille en clair c'est la tonalité
aujourd'hui
rapport du coi discours de la Premier
ministre que la route contribue aux
forces investissements prévus pour le
rail et on l'a dit on a un potentiel de
pH qui n'est pas assuré à l'avenir
rouvignette
certains parlent d'une réduction de 50 à
70% de ce que ça rapporte
alors surtout si on en élargit pas le
périmètre nous en Alsace d'une certaine
façon on va procéder à cette
élargissement donc vous l'aurez compris
mes questions comment réussir
effectivement la décarbonation et
comment voyez-vous la perspective d'un
bien plus important abondement de la
route pour les investissements des modes
durables et particulièrement du rail
merci chers collègues je vais donner la
parole à Bruno Belin pour le groupe les
républicains
merci monsieur le Président mais c'est
grave pour votre présentation complète
en ouverture de notre échange alors pas
question de s'en prendre au bébé au
contraire vous allez devant vous que des
sénateurs de province et donc nous
savons combien les autoroutes sont
importants pour les territoires que nous
représentons pour leur directe pour la
mobilité pour l'activité économique
touristique donc
mais ça n'empêche quand même pas un
certain nombre de questions voilà on
voit bien quand même que la question de
la rentabilité et du modèle de
rentabilité évidemment fait réagir ici
cette maison avec
voilà deux questions qui ont été
avancées sur notamment faut-il diminuer
la durée le coût de ces concessions
évidemment quel modèle de vous
imagineriez après comme modèle idéal
nouveau modèle économique au-delà de
l'échéance dont on a déjà parlé quelle
évolution pour améliorer le service
rendu aussi puisque évidemment derrière
il n'y a que des usagers vous l'avez dit
ce sont les usagers qui payent mais quel
modèle pour améliorer le service rendu
bien évidemment la question des tarifs
se pose alors vous allez me dire que
vous êtes sur une indexation à
l'inflation
qu'elle est par la loi mais justement
dans une période où on voit bien quand
même que nos concitoyens sont sensibles
à cette inflation forte
qui nous concerne tous comment vous
envisageriez une adaptation une révision
de ces tarifs et puis dernier point lit
aussi à la décarbonation nous les voyons
quel est votre plan de déploiement des
bornes électriques et qu'elle est tout
simplement votre trajectoire
d'investissement pour les prochaines
années merci
qui est un collègue la parole est à pour
le groupe sera Olivier Jacqueline merci
monsieur le Président
Monsieur le Directeur je vous ai bien
écouté vous avez déjà emmené des
éléments de réponse substantielle je
vais adapter donc mon questionnement et
produire 4 questions et une question au
président Longeot
tout d'abord Bruno Le Maire a annoncé la
semaine dernière qu'il saisissait le
Conseil d'État
je ne me trompe pas président donc Bruno
Le Maire a annoncé la semaine dernière
qu'il saisissait le Conseil d'État pour
faire suite aux recommandations de l'IGF
quel est votre appréciation des trois
scénarios préconisés à savoir la
diminution de la durée des contrats le
prélèvement sur les bénéfices ou la
baisse des péages j'aimerais là-dessus
une réponse précise monsieur
il m'envient une autre à partir de cela
notre collègue Vincent de laïque nous
avons entendu
l'engagement pugnace évoque pour
retrouver une économie normale de ces
contrats la possibilité d'investir 30 à
35 milliards en plus d'ici la fin de ces
contrats est-ce pour vous une solution
par exemple pour le verdissement ou pour
développer le flux libre par exemple
sur le bon état vous avez amené des
réponses des éléments de réponse
satisfaisant en évoquant les deux
avenants récents de l'État dont je crois
comprendre que pour vous la question du
bon état ne se pose plus avec ces
nouveaux indicateurs à répondre alors je
pose ma question autrement selon vous
combien de temps est-il doit disposer la
puissance publique pour mettre fin à ses
contrats et envisager de nouveaux
contrats
ultérieurement troisième question avec
des chercheurs j'ai interrogé le
gouvernement sur le non respect de
l'article
r31314 du code de la commande publique
sur la nécessité pour les
concessionnaires de produits chaque
année un rapport comportant notamment un
inventaire des biens désignés au contrat
comme bien de retour et de reprise du
service concédé avez-vous produit ces
rapports si ce n'est pas le cas comment
le justifier vous alors qu'il s'agit
d'une obligation légale
quatrième point je viens de déposer une
proposition de résolution sur la
création d'un modèle alternatif à celui
des concessions déséquilibrées que nous
connaissons aujourd'hui avec la
commission d'enquête de 2020 nous avons
mis en avant que l'un des principaux
objets de ce déséquilibre résidés dans
l'inclusion du risque trafic au modèle
concessif autoroutier ce risque trafic
explique en très grande partie le niveau
des tri que même le ministre le maire
n'arrive plus à justifier alors ma
question vous exploitez la concession
Léonore à Lyon qui ne comprend pas ce
risque trafic qui prouverait donc que
les autoroutiers puisque le marché a été
pourvu il trouverait tout de même leur
compte pouvez-vous nous faire un retour
d'expérience de la concession léonaire à
Lyon et nous dire si ce modèle est
attractif pour vous et que pensez-vous
de cette proposition et ma question au
président longeauge pour terminer
c'est de faire la proposition de
réaliser l'audition du ministre Lemaire
et peut-être du ministre Beaune
concomitamment et peut-être en lien avec
la commission des finances car j'ai très
envie de leur poser un certain nombre de
questions qui ne relèvent pas des
concessionnaires et notamment de savoir
ce qu'ils ont fait entre 2021 date du
rapport de l'IGF et la date
d'aujourd'hui alors que seulement
aujourd'hui il se réveille je vous
remercie
merci merci pour l'audition des deux
ministres on va parler mais oui ça peut
être une éventualité tout à fait très
bien on va en parler avant donc merci
le directeur général vous avez la parole
merci beaucoup pour toutes ces questions
qui sont qui sont très nombreuses sur
lequel je comprends que vous souhaitez
des réponses précises donc je vais je
m'excuse si j'ai pas totalement tout
noté mais je vais essayer de faire un
balayage général
je vais répondre à tout point point
voilà point point alors on va on va
commencer par par le sujet d'actualité
histoire de je veux pas dire de
l'évacuer parce que je pense qu'il va
être difficile avec eux ce sujet mais de
manière à le mettre sur la table donc
effectivement il y a eu ce rapport de
l'Inspection générale des finances dont
nous avions nous non plus d'ailleurs pas
pas connaissance qui a été qui est sorti
donc qui donne des calculs de
rentabilité du théorie du Terry projet
du terrier actionnaire je ne rentre pas
dans ces dans ces dans ces détails
techniques et qui
donne des résultats voilà qui montrent
que le groupe le groupe bref aurait et
là pour le coup je mets du conditionnel
aurait voilà un théorie à peu près dans
les dans l'ordre de grandeur de ce qui
était prévu au début et sachant que
c'est très référence elle est pas très
connue de nous et puis d'autres groupes
auraient des rentabilités supérieures
moi j'ai pris connaissance de ce rapport
il y a une semaine comme vous ce rapport
ne donne pas le modèle le modèle
financier détaillé qui donne ce qui
donne ce résultat donc en bonne
ingénieur je suis incapable de vous dire
si ces chiffres est juste pas juste si
je suis d'accord ou non avec ce chiffre
voilà aujourd'hui le chiffre est posé
sur la table d'ailleurs si on lit bien
le rapport on voit que l'Inspection
générale des finances et le CGD prennent
beaucoup de pincettes autour de ces
chiffres en disant ça dépend des des de
ce qui va se passer à l'avenir ça dépend
de certains d'hypothèses ça dépend du
trafic ça dépend de beaucoup de choses
mais évidemment tout ce qu'on retient
c'est comme ça c'est il y a sur
rentabilité alors je veux pas le sujet
s'agissant du groupe du groupe SANEF et
de son accélér à berthys je l'ai déjà
dit dans la commission d'enquête il y a
deux ans et je le redis aujourd'hui la
rentabilité que nous avons c'est peu
Prous celle qui était prévue prévue à
l'origine même si et je le redis aussi
c'est plus de 1 milliard si on regarde
la séquence de chiffre d'affaires entre
la private des nations et maintenant
c'est pratiquement plus de 1 milliard de
chiffre d'affaires qui n'ont pas qui
n'ont pas été réalisés par rapport au
modèle initial donc c'est un milliard
d'euros qui quelque part que les que les
que les usagers de l'autoroute n'ont pas
payé voilà
néanmoins l'un dans l'autre on arrive à
peu près à cette rentabilité quant aux
propositions de l'Inspection des
finances reprises par le par le par le
ministre par le ministre des Finances et
ministres des Transports moi j'ai rien
de spécial à dire tout ce que je peux
vous dire c'est qu'il n'existe pas un
article au contrat qui permet sur la sur
la base d'une supposée sur rentabilité
du terrier actionnaire il n'existe pas
un contrat qui permet un article qui
permet de réduire voilà
la question certainement considérées si
tu avais été évident je pense que on en
parlera pas il existe un article 38 qui
permet de réduire la durée de la
concession moyennant une juste
compensation qui se finirait grosso modo
à dire d'experts voilà quant aux autres
solutions la solution de la fiscalité et
la solution
la solution de la fiscalité notamment
c'est une solution qui me paraît
particulièrement injuste puisque comme
on peut on appliquer une fiscalité
homogène en supposant que les calculs de
le de l'Inspection générale des finances
sont se révèle et juste par rapport à la
réalité à la réalité et aux projections
à l'avenir comment pourrait-on imaginer
qu'il y ait une fiscalité homogène sur
le sur les réseaux autoroutier qui alors
que les résultats fallait les
rentabilités sont différentes et que
dans une grande société d'autoroute qui
n'a jamais été privatisée qui est Koffi
route
qui serait de du coup
taxer
sur un fondement qui n'existe pas donc
là je je j'aimais des doutes et je ne
suis pas je ne suis pas le Conseil
d'État donc je voilà ce que je peux vous
dire voilà ce que je peux vous dire sur
ce sujet
sur les sur les tarifs puisque vous avez
parlé évidemment
les uns les autres des tarifs je reviens
pas sur la formule vous l'avez vu on a
de manière régulière mis en place des et
à la demande dernièrement de de du
ministre des Transports mis en place des
des formules d'abonnement des formules
d'abonnement qui sont efficaces
puisqu'il permettent d'obtenir 40% de
réduction sur les tarifs de péage sur
les trajets du quotidien qui sont les
trajets qui pèsent le plus sur les
Français et quand et sur l'aspect tarif
et des carbonations nous avons mis en
place une réduction de 5 sur l'ensemble
des des tarifs de péage pour les pour
les véhicules électriques ça ça fait pas
toute la décarbonation et j'en viens au
sujet de la de la de la décarbonation je
l'ai dit tout à l'heure au moment où on
parle nous avons dans un temps record
non pas dans dans un an un peu moins
d'un an et demi nous avons installé
400 presque 500 bornes je j'arrondis un
peu pratiquement 500 bornes à haute
puissance sur les réseaux du groupe du
groupe du groupe SANEF donc aujourd'hui
et avec dans nos contrats de
sous-conception puisqu'on l'a fait par
le mode de la sous-concession avec une
obligation pour le preneur de réadapter
le nombre de bornes en fonction de du
taux d'occupation donc on a
contractuellement voilà gérer voilà pour
un peu que la modèle du véhicule
électrique soit un modèle qui soit
pérenne pour les pour les 10 ans qui
viennent on a géré le sujet de la des
bornes de recharge électrique pour les
véhicules légers
reste un autre sujet qui est je l'ai dit
tout à l'heure qui sont les poids lourds
sur les poids lourds vous parliez
partenariats les uns des autres de
partenariat avec l'État nous avons
commencé nous avec notre consédant à
réfléchir à quelque chose qui va arriver
il y a un règlement européen qui
s'appelle le réglement affirme
qui va devenir applicable très très
bientôt dans l'ensemble des pays membres
qui recommande des installations enfin
qui recommande qui qui rend obligatoire
des installations de recharge pour les
poids lourds et nous avons je crois nous
sommes d'ailleurs je crois un des
premiers concessionnaires autoroutiers à
cette rencontre avec les services de
l'État en disant voilà cette chose là va
arriver qu'est-ce que l'on fait
qu'est-ce que ça veut dire sur la
restructuration notre infrastructure
puisque faire charger des centaines de
poids lourds sur une aire ça ne peut pas
se faire avec la même aire de de service
que celle qu'on a aujourd'hui ça peut
décider ça va nécessiter des
investissements ça va être des amener
d'énergie absolument considérables
aujourd'hui on a deux mégawatts entre 2
et 5 mégawatts sur chaque sur chaque air
ça veut dire 20 mégawatts 40 mégawatts
d'électricité qui vont arriver sur
chacun donc c'est une autre dimension et
c'est une autre dimension que vous
parlez d'investissement que les
concessionnaires eux ne peuvent pas
porter complètement seuls peuvent porter
seul d'un point de vue technique puisque
ça dépend de un arralement europ éen de
de de d'un schéma directeur d'un schéma
directeur global et là où je fais le
parallèle avec le véhicule électrique là
où le véhicule électrique il a pu
débuter dans l'urbain
avec des temps de charge long avec des
parcours le poids lourd c'est
fondamentalement différent puisque le
poids lourd par définition il fait
plutôt des longues distances et par
définition le polo est circule plutôt
sur l'autoroute alors que la petite
citadine
urbaine circulait et circuler dans et
circuler dans dans l'urbain il faisait
pas d'interogan donc là on a on a des
enjeux et on a des enjeux qui sont qui
ne peuvent être résolus moi j'ai pas de
solution miracle moi je peux pas vous
dire devant vous que la solution c'est
de mettre des bandes de recharge
hydrogène partout c'est de faire de la
route électrique et de faire moi je ne
se le sais pas voilà je suis désolé mais
ce que je sais c'est que on a cet enjeu
dans les années qui viennent et qu'on
doit collaborer là-dessus vous avez
parlé les uns ou les autres
d'auto-solisme et c'est effectivement un
des grands enjeux du périurbain et
d'ores et déjà dans l'avenant qu'on
citer qui a été signé là en janvier nous
avons des investissements sur des pôles
d'échanges multimodo de manière à
pouvoir
à pouvoir permettre le passage sur des
sur des modes de transport collectifs à
partir de parking de covoiturage de très
très grande taille le les voies
réservées vous avez parlé du flux libre
on nous sommes les les premiers à avoir
signé il y a deux ans un
la conversion en flux libre de
l'autoroute A13 le flux libre qui est à
la fois du gain de temps mais aussi des
économies de CO2 pour pour pour
l'ensemble des Français et à la fin des
économies de carburant on parle d'argent
mais c'est aussi des économies de
carburant et on croit que le modèle du
flux libre fait partie de l'ensemble de
la décarbonation alors c'est pas l'alpha
et le méga rien et l'alpha Omega de la
décarbonation et c'est un ensemble de
mesures qui vont faire que nous allons
réussir ce challenge qui est un
challenge qui a dit vital pour tous et
j'en viens à une de vos questions et et
c'est quelque chose qui ne pourra pas
atteindre la atteindre la fin des
concessions et donc il va falloir
trouver les les moyens
les moyens de réaliser ces
investissements maintenant puisque sans
ces investissements on n'arrivera pas à
atteindre les objectifs que l'on se fixe
que l'on se fixe collectivement en
matière de décarbonation ça passe par un
partenariat entre l'État les
concessionnaires et moi je dois vous
dire une chose on parle beaucoup de
relations déséquilibrées de relations
par coup de lettres d'avocat va de ce
genre de choses moi je peux vous dire
mon quotidien de concessionnaire on a
une relation de bonne qualité avec les
services de l'État qui défendent
extrêmement bien extrêmement bien les
intérêts de l'État quand un avenant
quand on signe un avenant un autre
contrat de concession il est vérifié par
la RT il est évidemment vérifié par le
concessionnaire bien entendu il est
vérifié par la RT qui donne un avis dans
lequel nous prenons en compte les les
avis de les avis de la RT ensuite on
passe au Conseil d'État qui lui-même a
toute une série toute une série donc
dans la série dans le dans le
déséquilibre peut-être il y a eu des
équipes dans le passé moi je peux vous
dire qu'il y a pas de il y a pas
déséquilibre on a une bonne relation de
travail on aura la relation de travail
de partenariat avec les services de
l'État et c'est bien comme ça vous
l'avez dit Monsieur et je suis d'accord
avec vous et c'est bien comme ça qu'on
va construire l'avenir et c'est pas
forcément et c'est pas
en opposant les usagers les actionnaires
voilà
j'irai pas plus loin là-dessus d'autant
que le sujet du terrier actionnaire
n'est apparemment pas un sujet en ce qui
nous en ce qui nous concerne mais je ne
je pense que ça n'est pas forcément une
façon vertueuse de pros de se projeter
dans l'avenir d'opposer d'un côté les
les actionnaires et les usagers d'autant
que
d'autant que le aujourd'hui on parle
pour certains groupes et j'irai pas plus
loin parce que ça ne me concerne pas
directement de sur rentabilité du niveau
des actionnaires qui en fait
principalement lieu pas tellement pas
tellement au trafic mais surtout à la
variations des taux les variations des
taux
j'ai envie de dire de façon presque
provocante y aurait-il eu si les taux
avaient doublé par rapport au taux de la
privatisation il y aura utiles un
rapport de l'gf qui montrait qui qui
montrait que le taux de rentabilité
était de 4%, non certainement pas donc
là on est dans un dans un schéma qui me
paraît parfois un peu un peu un peu
étrange mais c'est mais c'est
malheureusement comme ça en ce qui
concerne les modèles de des modèles de
concession je vous l'ai dit tout à
l'heure le groupe averti s'exploite des
concessions dans le monde entier
et il existe plein de modèles de
concession plus réguliers en termes de
rentabilité on en est et on en exploite
au Chili par exemple des systèmes avec
des durées variables en fonction du en
fonction du chiffre d'affaires réalisés
je suis pas sûr que ça soit exactement
ce qui ce qui résoudrait les
questionnements aujourd'hui il existe
des des systèmes en Italie avec des
systèmes de tous les 5 ans de clauses de
clause de revoyure
des systèmes
fonctionnels dans lequel on a on arrive
à allier l'équilibre de la gestion la
qualité de la gestion privée je pense
que personne personne ne revient dessus
la qualité de la gestion privée un
transfert de risque raisonnable mais des
clauses de revoyure ce sont des modèles
qui existent ailleurs et et qui sont le
quotidien qui sont de notre quotidien
dans d'autres pays du monde donc ça fait
des parties des choses qui peuvent
absolument être être envisagé
voilà ce que je peux
ce que je peux dire il faut
réinventer certes certes le modèle
réinventer le modèle tout en tout en
obérant pas l'avenir
c'est à dire que aujourd'hui il reste un
outil à disposition très important cet
outil doit être utilisé au maximum pour
pouvoir faire face aux enjeux de
décarbonation aux enjeux
environnementaux qui sont qui sont
devant nous tout en tout temps
respectant et en garantissant et c'est
très important pour des investisseurs
étrangers je me présente un peu comme
investisseur étrangers devant vous
aujourd'hui en garantissant la signature
de l'État vous avez une posée une
question sur sur la hausse de la de la
taxe d'aménagement du territoire
s'agissant d'un sujet sur lequel nous
avons un contention en cours je vais pas
pouvoir rentrer dans énormément de de
détails et vous le savez très bien nous
avons dans nos contrats une clause de
stabilité de la fiscalité spécifique
donc il est bien naturel
que si cette clause de
fiscalité et de stabilité pardon de la
fiscalité spécifique n'est pas respecté
par l'État qui est signataire de ce
contrat il est bien naturel voilà j'irai
pas plus loin là-dessus de ce de ce de
se défendre sur ce sur ce principe parce
que c'est un point de c'est un point de
principe et c'est un point qui qui
relève aussi de la qualité de signature
de l'État rappelons-nous une énorme
entorse qui s'est passé en 2015
rappelons-nous le gel des tarifs
autoroutiers opéré par par la ministre
de l'écologie en 2015 c'est quelque
chose qui n'est pas acceptable de ne pas
respecter de ne pas respecter ces
contrats et ça a un impact on parlait de
la potentielle mise en concurrence en
2030 pour attirer un une concurrence
plus importante et donc des
investisseurs étrangers pour des
investisseurs étrangers un des gros
atouts de la France c'est la qualité de
la signature de l'État
voilà on exploite par ailleurs des
autoroutes en Argentine c'est pas
exactement la même chose donc la signale
la qualité de la signature de l'État et
moi pour moi quelque chose de très
important et le respect de ces
engagements contractuel peut voir il
peut regretter d'avoir pris ces
engagements mais le regret le respect
des engagements contractuels et très
très important et très important pour
les investisseurs et pour les prêteurs
parce que je finis par là on parle de la
dette le modèle de développement des
infrastructures dans tous les pays du
monde et depuis 1950 en France et basé
sur de sur de la dette c'est un modèle
qui est extrêmement vertueux un modèle
qui est extrêmement vertueux et et on se
ceux qui ont qui lisent un petit peu
d'histoire se rappelle que dans les
années 90 il y avait une énorme
inquiétude sur la dette des autoroutes
elle était au niveau de la dette de la
SNCF voilà et ben le le l'avantage de ce
modèle c'est que nous avons pris en 2006
des autoroutes endettées ou des sociétés
de route lourdes endettée et je peux
vous garantir une chose quel qu'en soit
le taux
est à 2% ou le taux est à 12 pour le
taux est à 12% les autoroutes sont
rendus à la fin de la concession
complètement désendettés et c'est là
aussi voilà d'un point de vue c'est plus
sur un sur un volet financier un des
grands avantages de la concession voilà
j'espère avoir répondu à vos très très
nombreuses questions
bien ben je vous remercie je vous
remercie pour effectivement répondre à
nos questions merci effectivement pour
la clarté de vos propos et puis bien je
vais lever la séance en
ayant une pensée pour notre collègue
Joël Bigot qui a perdu sa maman donc
voilà une pensée pour jouer Le Bigot et
puis bien merci et nous continuerons
notre cycle d'audition la semaine
prochaine
sur ce même sujet merci à vous vous êtes
prêtés à la réponse à nos questions
merci merci